okay for people who are joining this
livestream is a little different from
usual live streams that I've done first
of all I'm on video with my totally
messy office here but second of all this
is primarily for kids and my goal is to
try to do my best
answering science questions about pretty
much any topic so who would like to
start off here with a question about
something science II and I need to be
able to actually see these questions or
I'm not going to be able to respond so
we can talk about physically things
mathy things computer science biology
okay let's see what we have
um okay we have one initial question
here which is what is my favorite
science thing to work on well that's a
complicated story what I've been working
on for a long time is computational
languages trying to make languages that
humans can understand that best explain
things to computers that's been the
long-running story of things I've been
doing but more recently I have restarted
a project that I had been working on for
a long time which is the which has to do
with physics and I was well been
interested for a long time and what so
the fundamental theory of physics says
maybe we'll talk about that later if
people are interested let me not get
started on that right now there's a
bunch of new news on that that I will be
talking about a lot of it wasn't for
this pesky virus that is trying to take
over the world although it won't succeed
um all right it was a question here what
happened to the dinosaurs well gosh so
far as people can tell the so first
point is for a long time
dinosaurs were only comparatively
recently discovered people had thought
you know there might be dragons and
things and they'd been sort of stories
about how there were dragons but nobody
really knew about that and then in the
1800s 150 years ago or something people
really started systematically finding
fossils and they found fossils that were
kind of reminiscent of of dragons and
those were fossils of dinosaurs and it
was only only in the 1800s that sort of
the idea that there had been these large
creatures that lived a long time ago
really sort of emerged and it became
clear that the dinosaurs had lived up
until about 65 million years ago and
then they disappeared and for a long
time when I was a kid
it was like why had the dinosaurs
disappeared answer because the dinosaurs
are reptiles they're cold-blooded etc
etc etc long people had said had come
the mammals and the mammals were just a
much better collection of critters and
we're of course mammals and it's like we
were the winners the dinosaurs were the
losers and it was just like the mammals
there were all kinds of stories about
the mammals ate the dinosaur eggs etc
etc that's why the dinosaurs died out
that was the story and there were these
people I knew them they were physicists
who said actually there's another
possibility the possibility is maybe an
asteroid hit the earth and and caused
the earth to get really cold for a
couple of years because it threw a bunch
of dust up into the atmosphere and that
covered the Sun and things got really
cold and dinosaurs died out as a result
of that and at the beginning this looked
like a completely crazy theory because
it seemed like you know why would
anybody think that would happen and it
was was just all all looked very
implausible and then what was discovered
was that all over the earth there's this
tiny layer I think it's a Veridian
osmium I'm not don't completely remember
of a very of a rare chemical rare
element that exists as a little little
layer that you can find if you dig down
in rocks and you find so when you know
when rocks form they tend to be in these
layers where the most recent rocks are
on top and the earlier rocks are
underneath so you can get kind of an
idea of what's how old by sort of
digging down and seeing what layer you
hit what at and so what happened is the
there's this layer all over the earth of
these unusual it's unusual elements that
have that occurs in asteroids but isn't
really common on the earth and so this
what seemed like a completely crazy
theory actually turned out to be true
and it turned out 65 million years ago
there was this asteroid that hit the
earth near the Gulf of Mexico I guess
and sort of threw up a bunch of dust or
so this is kind of relevant if you are
if you're interested in kind of global
warming climate change things like that
the fact that it's possible to have a
bunch of dust though
to the upper atmosphere that will cover
the Sun and cool things down is kind of
interesting it's kind of bad if you're a
dinosaur and you don't get to you know
make a fire and keep warm and so on but
that's um that's kind of the seems to
have been the story of what happened and
it's interesting that they've been at
several times in the history of the
earth there have been these asteroid
impacts it's it's something these days
one of the questions is can we tell if
there's going to be an asteroid that
collides with the earth and there are
various efforts to watch for asteroids
it's actually an interesting math
problem because you see an asteroid it's
on a certain orbit you have to compute
you have to solve these differential
equations to work out you know will the
asteroids orbit in fact intersect with
the orbit of the earth and it's possible
to do that these days and we'll know if
there's any serious risk of that the
question of what you do whether you can
go and send a spacecraft and nudge the
asteroid a little bit out of the way
there's pretty decent evidence that that
should be possible um so I don't think
we're not going to have an asteroid
I don't think caused us trouble but
there are other kinds of questions that
came up like it seemed like if you look
at the history of life on Earth there
seem to have been these periodic
extinctions that have happened where a
large fraction of species that existed
went extinct and one of them happened at
this KT boundary the cretaceous-tertiary
boundary 65 million years ago there were
other ones that have happened previously
there was one I think in the Cambrian
period 250 million years ago maybe um
that was fairly dramatic and possibly
they're all associated with asteroid
impacts and there was sort of a theory
for a while that I don't think turned
out to be correct that maybe there are
sort of just a whole crowd of asteroids
that are sort of orbiting around in the
solar system
and that every so often every 60 million
years or something that there'd be a
bunch of them near the earth that
doesn't seem to be true it seems to be
more of a random kind of thing all right
more questions here um okay lots of good
stuff here um the next question
anything I'd add or subtract from a new
kind of science I think that's a that's
a slightly non kid question but I'll try
and answer it so about 18 years ago now
I wrote a big book called a new kind of
science that really had to do with the
following thing it's some when you learn
about science in school elsewhere when
you learn about sort of the the fanciest
areas the areas of science were sort of
the most is know and probably the areas
like physics and one feature of those
areas is there's lots of math in those
areas when people make models of how
things work like motion of asteroids and
things they make those models in terms
of math equations and that's kind of why
why people one of the reasons people
think it's worthwhile to learn lots of
math and so on
I think math is a great subject and its
really worth learning we can talk about
some aspects of it that I think are more
unless worth learning later if people
are interested but in so but I was
interested in the question of there are
things in the world that are not so well
describable by math equations so for
example a lot of things in biology and
not so well describable if you say you
know what's the what's the shape of some
particular what's the shape of the
spines on a Stegosaurus not really a
great math equation question so the
issue is what what other kind of methods
can you use to make to figure out
questions like that other than by using
math and so what I got interested in is
can we write computer programs that will
figure those things out in a way that's
different from the way that math figures
those things out and turns out the
answer is yes and one of the things that
I studied a lot was you know when
usually when you write computer programs
you say I'm gonna write this program
it's gonna be for a specific purpose I'm
gonna write some fairly complicated
program that does some fairly
complicated thing but what I got
interested in is if you were just like
you know just typing randomly on a
keyboard and just typing programs very
simple kinds of programs what would
those programs typically do and if the
program is simple would the thing it
does be simple as well and the big
surprise is even though the program
maybe simple what it does isn't simple
and that turns into a lot a lot of ideas
about science and how things work in
nature and how complex stuff gets
produced in nature and so on and that's
why I wrote this big book about and kind
of the big thing is that math equations
had sort of been the dominant way that
people made science theories for 300
years since people like Galileo and
Newton had had suggested that in the in
the mid to late 1600s and so I was kind
of saying no actually there's this
additional approach that we can take
which is to use programs and computers
to do this and people at the time sort
of said some people said some people
said there's a great idea some people
said oh no no you know it's bender being
done a different way for 300 years
that's how it has to be done forever
well it turns out in the last 15 years
or so that this idea of using programs
to make models of things has really
become not just a thing but actually
really a winning thing and it's really
the way that the majority of new models
for things get made so that's been
that's been really successful one of the
things that I tried to make a model of
in my book is fundamental physics sort
of what happens underneath space and
time and so on
and I had gotten a fair distance in the
book doing that and then I kind of put
that project aside for a variety of
reasons and they actually last fall I
came back to it and I made sort of
spectacular progress and if I wasn't if
the world as I was saying earlier if the
world wasn't sort of covered in enviros
issues right now I'd be talking a lot
about the progress that I made because
it's really neat and I'll talk about it
here if people are interested but I see
there are lots of questions here and I
don't want to get too far behind so let
me um let me keep going here and the
question of would I add or subtract
things from a new kind of science the
main answer to that is well I don't know
once what it's a very big book it's a
1280 page book and there's probably you
know and you can find it online it's
it's free online and so on nice version
of it online it's probably the case I
you know I look at the book very
frequently because it's find it a very
useful reference because it's kind of a
summary of a lot of stuff that I know
there's probably 300 pages of those
1,200 pages that I
really look at a lot and maybe some of
the other pages could be not there but I
don't know about that in terms of things
I would add to it well there's a lot of
stuff that I wrote about a hundred pages
out of that 1200 pages was about physics
and there's a lot more to say there and
it's really exciting and I'm thrilled to
talk about it but let me not let me not
to derail this this discussion for
talking specifically about physics um so
the next question was what science
programming books do I recommend for
kids well I have to say you know we
we've built our whole Wolfram language
and Mathematica stack to kind of make it
possible for anybody to use computers to
do sophisticated things and I wrote a
little book called elementary
introduction to Wolfram language which
is free on the web and that book I kind
of aimed at kids kind of mmm high school
middle school ish kids it's actually
been a book that has been very popular
among adults as well but I think it
works well for kids and it's really a
very hands-on kind of introduction to to
computation for kids it's not so
specifically aimed at science although
it has a bunch of science II things in
it it's it's a good idea actually to
have such a version aimed at science but
I think it's that would be a really good
start actually tomorrow I've signed up
to do a live stream a sort of an
introduction to computation for kids and
I will talk about some of the probably
early stuff in that book there um ok
question was for age 8 or 10 I think
that that's the very low end of so so my
book I sort of claim as good starting at
about age maybe 11 although having said
that I know a bunch of 10 year olds who
have managed to be very successful with
it so so it is not it is not there's no
hard cutoff there I would say younger
than that it's a little challenging
there is our demonstrations project
where you'll find about 11,000
demonstrations I can I can pull these
things up I as a choice between them
me yakking on screen here and me pulling
things up the let me let me keep yakking
here and I will pull things up on the
screen a little bit later but I want to
mention our demonstrations project
demonstrations go from calm which is
about some 11,000 interactive
demonstrations of all sorts of things oh
I'll bring that up hold on one second
let me let me do this here just a second
how to move things around a little bit
um okay there we go
demonstrations okay here we go
so this is this is our demonstrations
project and you can run these things
either in the cloud or if you want to
run them more zip early you can download
the free notebook player or if you have
a version of Mathematica or one of our
more from language products it will run
in there as well but I think you'll find
here there is a kids and fun section um
which should have some some
demonstrations why isn't that is there
an all here for kids
over there we go for kids okay um so
there are these are all kinds of this is
actually one made by my has made many
years ago by my by my daughter Katherine
who when well that was a bunch of years
ago now she's a math graduate student so
so but this was this was done when she
was in mmm let's see can I do the
arithmetic when she must have been about
less than 10 yes 8 or something so this
was this was a little interactive
demonstration that we made um okay so
that will be one suggestion for that age
group all right let's see um I'm gonna
go I mean unshared oh I was let me just
show you before I forget let me just
show you one more thing um let me show
you the wanted let me show you um the
this is my little book about programming
for for kids and others and it's kind of
you you can take any of these these
inputs you can actually run them you can
run them a few um if you go to see if
you go to our cloud which is again
something you can get this cloud basic
access I have this is this is just a UK
you can get two free cloud basic access
and now you go there you can like paste
that input that I had there and you'll
get in that particular case a red thing
or I can go here paste that input I can
get I am hopefully a collection of
colors there
so this is this is this is a good place
to go for programming kinds of things
and what's really neat about our
language is that yes it's used by kids
it's also used by the world sort of top
research crowd same language same thing
you know once you learn it as a kid you
can keep using it forever
and we've kind of tried to make it our
goal is to automate it to the point
where the computer does as much as it
can automatically for you and so your
what what you get to do is the things
that um that are sort of good for humans
to do so there's a section about geo
computation I'm doing during computation
about things in geography anyway
tomorrow I will I will be talking a
little bit more about about this alright
let me go back to pure camera here and
let me see what the next um next
questions are okay so there's a question
about watching the movie boy who
harnessed the wind which I have not
watched kids wondering how windmills
actually work and generate energy okay
all right good question okay let's see
what the easiest way to explain this is
so what's kind of happening in a
windmill is the reverse of what's
happening in an electric car so an
electric car what you're doing is you're
turning electrical and turning energy
from a battery electrical energy into
mechanical motion turning the wheels of
the car around and it just so happens
the way physics are set up most effects
like that if you can go from electricity
to motion it turns out it's sort of a
basic fact of physics that you can
reverse things like that and you can say
let's go from motion to electricity and
that's essentially what's happening in a
windmill is that you're running kind of
electric motor in Reverse
the wind is is turning the sails of the
the blades of the windmill and
and that's that's running the it's kind
of like running the electric car in
Reverse to go from from mechanical
motion to electrical energy now if you
ask how does that how does the windmill
work why does the weight of the blades
of the windmill turn around they
actually turn around for they're kind of
doing the reverse of what the propeller
of an airplane would do so the propeller
of an airplane each each each propeller
blade is shaped so that it will try and
push air from the engine of the plane as
making the propeller go around and the
propeller babe is shaped so that it will
push air backwards and when they when
the air is pushed backwards that will
cause the airplane to go forwards that's
a another one of these sort of physics
principles that if you sort of push
momentum backwards it will make you go
forwards and so the the so sort of the
idea is that the windmill is kind of
like the propeller of a plane working
backwards in that case the wind is
blowing across the propeller which is
causing or the the the blades of the
windmill causing them to turn and then
that's causing the sort of reverse
electric car to work and making energy
now if you ask me why why is it the case
that when you how does it actually work
to get electric how does an electric
motor work for example okay that's a
little bit tricky it's a little tricky
and it has to do with features about
magnetism and electricity let me let me
I I would be if people are interested I
can try and tackle that one that's a
little bit non-trivial because it term I
mean I can just sort of tell you facts
about how electricity and magnetism work
but it's more fun if one can explain why
those facts are true and there's a bit
of a stack of physics that you have to
explain to explain whether those things
are true it all has to do with a thing
called electromagnetic induction which
is a phenomenon that um well okay so
people know about magnets right you've
seen magnets how the magnets work well
magnets are typical magnet is made of
I earn and what happens is inside so so
a magnet works gosh we have to go a
couple of levels here the magnet works
because each little iron atom inside the
magnet is acting like its own little
tiny magnet but the question is how do
those things act like tiny magnets how
do you get how do you get a magnetic
field magnetism from anything else it
turns out that when you have an electric
current when you have electricity
flowing electricity flowing produces a
magnetic field and what is electricity
electricity is a flow of electrons so
electrons are these little tiny
particles that exist in every atom but
in a in a metal and which is like a
thing like a wire that conducts
electricity it turns out that some of
the the electrons usually electrons are
stuck inside atoms there's a nucleus of
atoms with protons and neutrons there's
all sort of electrons going around
outside the nucleus and usually the
electrons are just sort of stuck inside
the atom but in a metal something
special happens their end up being
electrons that are not stuck inside
atoms their end up being electrons that
are delocalized that can sort of move
through the metal and so when you have
an electric current what's happening is
that electrons these delocalized
electrons are able to move through the
metal and that's and the electrons each
electron carries a little tiny amount of
electric charge and as those electrons
move through the metal they are
producing an electric current and one of
the facts about physics is that when you
have an electric current and you have a
moving electron it produces a magnetic
field so one of the things that you can
do is you can have electrons that are
moving in a circle you can have a
electric current that's just going
around in a circle so there are these
things called solenoids which are just
sort of loops of wire that are turned
around many times a a solenoid with a
bunch of loops of wire the electrons are
just going around and around and round
these loops of wire and they're
producing magnetic field and the way it
works it's a little bit complicated the
the magnetic field is at right angles to
the direction of the of the
the electrons and so when you think
through the geometry it means that in
this loop of wire there's a magnetic
field that is pointing right out of the
loop of wires of the loops going round
this way the magnetic field is pointing
that way so when you what's actually
happening inside the iron is roughly
roughly roughly roughly I'm cheating a
little bit but roughly the electrons
inside the iron atom they're kind of
going round their nuclei and they're
kind of being like tiny versions of
those loops of wire those electrons
going around loops of wire and they're
making income making a magnetic field
and that's what the individual little
magnets that make up the magnetic field
from a block of iron that's what they
come from okay so given this fact that a
an electron that's moving produces a
magnetic field it and another fact is
that a magnetic field makes an electron
move when you sort of combine those
facts together and use a bit of kind of
engineering cleverness you can make that
turn into how an electric motor works
I can explain more people are interested
but let me let me keep going because I
see there are lots of questions here and
I want to want to move through a got a
bunch of things here um okay there's a
question about about fundamental physics
let me not tackle that right now okay
what is a virus why don't we have
medicines for viruses why do only
vaccines whereas for bacteria we have
antibiotics okay let me try and explain
that okay so you know we are
multicellular organisms we have lots of
cells in our bodies we have about I
think it's about a hundred trillion
cells in our body there are much simpler
organisms which have just one cell so
bacteria are an example of single cell
of organisms that effectively have that
they're sort of freestanding organisms
that are a sort of single biological
cell and we in fact we kind of coexist
with lots of bacteria in our in our gut
for example we've got tons of bacteria
it's always enter
when you talk to scientists who study
different kinds of organisms they're
very fond of pointing out if you talk to
people who study microorganisms like
bacteria they're very fond of pointing
out that the total number of bacterial
cells in a typical human is larger than
the total number of human cells in the
human we have more bacterial cells
living in us than we have cells of our
own of our own body but and then when
you talk to people who study virology
they say oh but but compared to the
bacteria the the the microbiology people
studying bacteria
you've got to realize we have even more
viruses in us than there are bacteria in
us but okay so a bacterium is a
free-standing organism that can
replicate on its own and so every I
don't know how often it is every maybe
couple of hours some bacterium will
split in two and you'll it'll it'll make
a a copy of the bacterium and so in
general the way life on earth works one
one common theme of all life on Earth is
it all uses well it mostly uses DNA it
all uses RNA these are molecules so so
in US for example DNA is the molecule
that kind of specifies how all of our
cells should work it's kind of like a
program it's a program that has about
six billion letters and it's six billion
base pairs so if you for example I you
can get your genome sequenced you can
find out what all those six billion base
pairs for you are so back in 2010 or
something I got my genome sequenced and
I was one of the fairly early humans to
do that it was kind of fun because you
know you get back this very ceremonial
disk drive that is like here is your
genome this is you so to speak this is
the six billion base pairs that specify
well specify most of what it needs to
make you you actually need some some
other tissue that is that is sort of
passed down through the species as well
as the actual pure DNA but anyway so
so we're specified by about six billion
base pairs
and every every different organism has a
different every different person has
slightly different DNA every different
organism has substantially different DNA
although it's kind of embarrassing how
much DNA we share with even very low
organisms and you know you might think
things like the longer your DNA the more
sophisticated an organism you are but
that's not true I think potatoes have
really long they're plants with really
long DNA sequences I think crabs also
have really long DNA sequences possibly
because they don't use quite the they
don't use all the letters in the genetic
code as much as we do but in any case so
bacteria sort of freely replicating
organisms what was discovered in the
1920's 1930's was that there are
chemicals that will just kill bacteria
and don't harm our ordinary cells
bacterial cells are called prokaryotic
cells our cells are called eukaryotic
cells there are there are chemicals that
the first one that was discovered was
penicillin and the was sort of
discovered by chance but what what does
penicillin do well penicillin is an
example of an antibiotic on a bacterium
attacking medicine and what penicillin
in particular does is the the cell walls
of bacteria are slightly differently set
up than the cell walls of our mammalian
cells and penicillin is really bad for
the cell walls of bacteria it just
basically destroys them and the bacteria
kind of explode and but it doesn't hurt
our cells and so that's why that's
that's how those antibiotics work is
they they they're they have features
that attack bacterial cells but leave
our cells unharmed and that's some and
and different antibiotics attack
different features of bacteria and one
of the problems is that just as life on
Earth is kind of evolved to have
different kinds of organisms and so on
so bacteria are evolved and it's it's a
it's always a challenge to get
antibiotics that will sort of kill the
latest bacteria because the bacteria
that evolved particularly in hospitals
tend to evolve specifically to kind of
avoid being attacked by the Bayer the
antibiotics that exist but it's kind of
roughly how a bacterial work now viruses
have a different scheme viruses are kind
of just sort of pure program they're
just DNA or RNA in the case of the
corona virus it's an RNA virus so DNA is
the sort of basic program that gets
replicated in all the cells in our
bodies RNA is kind of an intermediary
molecule that is kind of like a half of
a DNA molecule that is part of the
process of going of actually using the
program because you know we have these
six billion base pairs but what do they
actually do well what they do is they
say how to build all the stuff that's
going to turn into muscle and bone and
skin and all these different things that
we have in our bodies and the way that
works is in those six billion base pairs
they're about maybe 30,000 genes each of
those genes is like a little function
little little tiny program and one of
those genes might be the gene that makes
a particular thing that's relevant for I
don't know like I don't know rhodopsin
or something which is a protein that is
associated with how you how you sense
light in your eyes but each so we're
made of that the main stuff that makes
us up is a bunch of protein molecules
which are long long molecules that and
the and what the the the sort of the the
blueprint the specification of these
proteins is given by the program that
exists on the DNA and so when when we
make things for ourselves so to speak
all the time we're making new cells like
our skin flakes off when we make new
skin cells and so on the specification
of how those cells work is given by the
program in our DNA and that gets
activated different parts of that
program get activated and they'll be a
part that's for making the the proteins
the molecules that make up pieces of
skin and that part will get activated
for our skin so to make a skin cell and
that's how we that's how we make pieces
of ourselves from our DNA from the from
the program essentially in our DNA now
okay viruses have a have a have a thing
that they've figured out to do what they
do is they say they've got a program to
and their program is all about making
some proteins for virus and making more
virus and what they do is they try to
get our cells they try to hijack our
cells and get our cells to make that bad
RNA or their proteins instead of the
things that we should be making for
ourselves so a typical virus will go
it's it's got to have a bunch of tricks
because it's got to the virus is just
floating around outside ourselves our
cells have sort of membrane skins around
them and the virus has to figure out
sort of how to get inside the cell and
how to get all the way to the point
where it can use the the sort of
apparatus that exists the molecular
apparatus that exists inside cells and
kind of get that molecular apparatus
making its proteins or its RNA instead
of ours and that's what viruses do to us
is they get into our cells and they
start producing copies of the virus or
other kinds of things rather than
letting those cells do what they should
have done so the way that we get rid of
viruses is our cells are constantly
looking at kind of what's inside the the
cell and they're trying to expose little
pieces of proteins and RNA and things on
the surface of the cell and then our
immune system goes around and checks our
cells and tries to make sure that our
cells only have the right little program
fragments exposed on their surface it's
really a tricky thing it's an
interesting piece of math the it takes
only the in the the the the program the
genetic code that's in our DNA has these
four kinds of things a G C and T um and
it doesn't take a very long sequence of
a G C and T before you can say that
sequence never occurs in in you so for
example if I typed in we can do that in
our malphur program if I typed in a
random okay I have to have to do this
just for an
example here let me try and arrange
things I can do this hold on one second
I'm gonna just share my screen again and
let me try doing this okay so let me go
to off malphur um see let me just try
typing in some sequence here oops
I'm gonna type in some sequence of A's
and B's and C's and T's and so this is
um it's going to assume that this is a
base pair sequence and it was going to
tell me here that that particular
sequence doesn't occur anywhere on the
human genome so in other words if your
cell showed up with that sequence in it
your immune system could potentially say
no that's not right that's not part of a
human genome I don't want that I want to
get rid of that cell now if I make this
short enough let's make this
significantly shorter just so in this
case with 15 base pairs okay this is
saying actually this is something which
occurs in a typical human genome there's
some let's see how many is it there's
one match on chromosome 13 and we can
see that that particular match on
chromosome 13 is inside this program
this gene SOG a to p1 we could click on
this we could find out what that program
does probably let's see okay it's a
human gene that makes nadh dehydrogenase
ubiquinone okay I think I have some idea
what that might do but um it's it's
something somewhere sort of deep where
actually it says here functions protein
binding mitochondrial inner membrane etc
etc etc so this is like a tiny piece of
the program that makes us humans but the
thing I was showing you is if what is
exposed on the surface of the cell is
something which corresponds to a
sequence here that is a note couldn't be
a human genome sequence and that's
something that your immune system can go
and attack and that's kind of what your
immune system is doing is it's saying
that's a thing that I don't expect
that's a thing that shouldn't be there
let me go attack it and so the way that
works there's a whole collection of
these things called b-cells and t-cells
and so on it's kind of one of the things
I find interesting when I learnt biology
when I was a kid it was there are two
kinds of blood cells red blood cells and
white blood cells well now I go look at
the biology literature and it's like
there aren't just white blood cells
there are T cells there are B cells
there are cd8 plus T cells there are
there's just a whole giant zoo of
different kinds of cells in our blood
the white blood cells are the main ones
that are associated with the immune
system and the immune system is a pretty
complicated thing but basically what
happens is the it notices that there are
things that are not part of that
shouldn't be there
that aren't part of your human genome
and sometimes so what happens when
you're a kid particularly think of the
thymus gland is responsible for kind of
training your immune system to say
what's what's you and what's not you and
what it's going to do is it's going to
say if it ever sees some sequence that
isn't a you sequence go attack it it
sees a sequence that is a you sequence
it's like okay that's fine no problem
when you get allergies autoimmune
diseases what's happening is that it got
a little bit hyperactive and decided
that it would go go after things which
actually are you kinds of things um and
you have to kind of persuade it not to
do that but but but in any case in that
usually when it's attacking something
like a virus what happens is the virus
infects the cell the cell conveniently
is exposing some information about
what's going on inside the cell on the
surface the immune system notices it's
the wrong thing that's happening there
it marks the cell and then eventually
other cells come along I think it's the
killer T cells of remember correctly
come along and actually the the cells
that have been marked as being
something's going wrong with the cell it
will get rid of them and and will also
get rid of the virus so what happens
when when we get sick with a virus we
mount an immune response we generate
antibodies we generate them our immune
system gets activated we start noticing
oh there's something bad going on
let's go send in a bunch of cells to go
attack the attacker so to speak
what happens is when when we get sick
like that we get left over with a
collection of some of these B cells that
contain kind of keep a memory of of
things of attackers that we saw and when
we when we have that memory of an
attacker that we saw the immune system
can get triggered and go to work much
more efficiently so if we ever see that
same attacker again our immune system is
primed and we can go attack it and go
get rid of it and you can actually
measure these immunoglobulins which are
part of the the which are the the
antibodies and things in the immune
system you can actually measure if
you've ever been sick with some
particular disease you will be able to
find antibodies to that disease in you
for the rest of your life kind of
recording sort of waiting for a part of
the system that kind of waits for going
to attack that disease if you need to
ever attack that disease again so that's
kind of how we how we get immunity to
things as our immune system is primed to
go attack that disease because we have
these antibodies in this whole works a
little bit more complicated than that
but we have basically things that record
the sequences of the attacker and say if
you ever see this sequence again
mountain attack as quickly as possible
okay so the and the the reason that we
can't tum we can't use something like
antibiotics against viruses is that it's
the viruses have got into our own cells
so antibiotics are attack the whole cell
that is the bacterium in the case of a
virus it's our own cell that was
infected by that virus um and so the the
way so there are some few drugs that are
antiviral drugs and antiviral drugs try
to target aspects of the of the way that
cells that are helping very well the way
that viruses work or the way that cells
help viruses and they try and make it so
that it's more difficult for the cells
to help viruses so like REM is severe I
think is the the name of one drug that
might be active against a corona virus
against the the
19 disease and it I think it targets the
RNA it targets some aspect and now I'm
getting out of my depth here at Target
some aspect of the way the initiation of
RNA of transcription of RNA in the viral
for the viral RNA
I think but so in other words it's
trying to find some aspect of the way
that cells work that's different between
cells that are where it's doing viruses
the viruses work versus our work I might
mention you know this this nasty virus
it's a very little thing it's 29,000
base pairs is its complete genome so
we're at 6 billion base pairs it's a 29
thousand base pairs and it's it's trying
to just get as many copies as possible
of those 29 thousand base pairs but and
that's that's kind of what's happening
there so um just Oh to mention how
vaccines work so the basic idea of a
vaccine is to without you ever getting
the disease to have you kind of primed
so that your immune system is all ready
to jump into action if that disease ever
shows up so how do you do that well you
have to basically get your immune system
to record to get to create antibodies
and related things associated with what
would be an attack from that disease
without you getting the disease so the
way vaccines work is they take typically
some piece of a virus and because
because if you're going to get the virus
you get you the whole virus is going to
be in you so even if it's just the
coating outside the virus that your
immune system recognizes and says if
ever I see that coating go attack it
that's enough um you were in very early
vaccines it was like a whole virus that
might even have been alive but nowadays
it's it's like pieces of viruses and
dead viruses and so on um and but but so
the the real problem of viral vaccines
is how to get the immune system to
really mount
response and to kind of record the
information about the disease without
without you actually getting the disease
now when you with a vaccine because the
vaccine doesn't contain any actual virus
that can replicate you couldn't get the
disease from the vaccine but the problem
is how to get the vaccine how to get the
vaccine to sort of tell your immune
system go pay as much attention to this
as you would when you actually got the
disease and the way that works is that
vaccines have these things I think it's
called the adjuvant which is a an
additional substance that is sort of
mixed in with the actual sort of
fragments of virus virus parts and so on
that's mixed in and it when when you're
injected with a vaccine that adjuvant is
the thing that says to your immune
system hey something important is going
on here compared tension to this and so
then your immune system will come and
say oh this is important let's parade a
bunch of cells past here and get them to
record what's going on and and and it
will have an enhanced response your
immune system will have enhanced its
response and that's why it kind of gets
to to get a memory of of what what
happened even though you didn't fully
have the disease so that that's kind of
how vaccines work and the the tricky
things come about often in the way that
that agilent works and what other
effects that produces and things there
are tricky things there and that's why
it can take a while to develop vaccines
that are safe okay next question we have
here I'm sorry that was a rather ok next
question was are viruses alive I think I
explained a little bit of that so
viruses have so this particular virus
the corona virus is an RNA virus and it
doesn't have any possibility of being
sort of the only way it gets to to do
life like things like replicate itself
is by having a host whose cells it can
get to do that replication for them and
that that's why if we can get
whew enough people if we can get down to
no cases of this virus then the virus is
going to go extinct because after any
particular person after their immune
system mounts a vigorous enough defense
to kill off the virus in them unless the
virus has jumped to another person the
virus is toast they can't tell it can't
do any more because it can only survive
if it has a host in which to get its in
which to get copies of itself made so
let's see next question how to get
started in machine learning okay it's a
little bit more advanced
maybe tomorrow in my in my discussion
about introduction to computation I'll
talk a little bit about machine learning
but well let's see um
oh well say a few things here um mmm
let's see how many questions we've got
here no you know what I'm not gonna do
that here let me um I mean let me let me
table that for tomorrow um okay let's
see so the next question was a virus
does not have a cell how can be alive I
think I I think I talked about a little
bit about that um
let's see so this is next question is
about is it a problem if having
computational languages and having kids
learn computational languages and does
that mean kids won't learn sort of basic
things that they might over learn
otherwise learn you know the thing to
understand is progress is a lot of
what's happening is we're automating
more and more stuff like when I was a
kid oh gosh what wasn't automated I
don't know
stick shift cars okay every car was a
stick shift car pretty much at least in
England you know that's what you learnt
to drive with another Oh like it like
ink pens right I had an ink pen you know
ballpoint pens were kind of a slightly
modernistic thing and it was like a big
deal to not to be able to refill your
ink pen and not spill ink all over
yourself something I wasn't always
terribly good at um all kinds of things
like that these things gradually get
sort of automated away so when I was a
kid it was before electronic calculators
were common so electronic calculators
really came in it was kind of dramatic
for for 300 years people had used
abacuses slide rules slowly mechanical
calculators um and then in about two
years
electronic calculators came in at 1970
to 1972 and everybody started using
calculators to do arithmetic and so on
and you know the question so for example
I managed to just miss ever learning to
take square roots by hand in school and
I actually possibly due to obstinacy I
never learnt to do long division by hand
ever and in fact I the only ways I know
how to do that well my kids have showed
me how to do it a little bit but also
because I've taught computers how to do
how to do arithmetic and so on I've I've
learnt it that way although a little bit
embarrassingly the way computers do
arithmetic isn't the same as the way
that humans do arithmetic so for example
when you do if you know how to do long
multiplication
when you multiply two numbers and they
have let's say n digits in them the the
it takes you about N squared steps you
have to every digit has to get
multiplied by every other digit that's
the way humans do it
the way computers do it is vastly more
efficient than that for people who know
the stuff it's n log org and steps I
think it's there is the winner right now
um the and but the way computers do it
is something that will be so
unbelievably boring and unbelievably
detailed for humans the humans never do
it that way but so you know what happens
is there are these things that steadily
get automated that we humans don't end
up doing the thing that's neat is that
because some things got automated we can
do more stuff so because we could
automate doing some low-level
computation we can work out you know how
I don't know planetary orbit works or
something like this and and we can by we
I mean both I and any kid and so on can
play around with that stuff without
having to know you know all the details
about how to solve differential
equations and things like this so I
think the most important thing that
tends to happen is that one can kind of
by actually being able to do all these
examples and by being able to sort of
get to a higher level in things one can
get better intuition and understand more
things that one could have one had to
work through all the details oneself now
having said that when it comes to math
you know one of the things I think is a
shame about math is math is a really
beautiful subject and it's got a lot of
really interesting ideas it's probably
the single sort of intellectual artifact
the single sort of biggest intellectual
artifact that our civilization has
created the single thing where more
people have worked on it it's built up
more levels of knowledge than anything
else and it's really neat and there are
a lot of really interesting things in it
and unfortunately some part of what ends
up often getting taught in math is the
very mechanical parts of math you know
how do you you know how do you do long
multiplication how do you factor
polynomials things like this not the
parts of math that are like how do you
understand
I don't know the idea of how prime
numbers work work and how do you
understand a lot of things that are more
kind of they're as precise as as any of
these calculations but there are things
that are kind of talking about kind of
the the intellectual structure of math
rather than its mechanics and I think
sometimes it tends to be you know you've
got a bunch of kids and they're all
supposed to do some exercise and it's
like can we tell if you've already
actually did the exercise easier to tell
that if it's more mechanical but it's
really a shame because math is a very
beautiful subject and people and the
very beautiful things to understand
about it I'd be happy to talk about them
but people are interested things I think
are beautiful about them um and but
people often don't see that because they
end up I'm just seeing kind of the the
sort of mechanical parts of math when I
was a kid I kind of was very obstinate
about not liking the mechanical parts of
math and that's kind of how I came to
start trying to get computers to do the
mechanical parts of math because I was
really interested in physics which
involves lots of math and I was like I
really want to do this physics but I
really don't want to do this all this
mechanical part of math and so I taught
computers how to do that and that's what
eventually has led to things like
Wolfram Alpha and so on which have I
hoped helped a lot of other people to do
math too um
okay so there's a question here why
can't we see all light okay let's let me
try tackling that so so okay so light we
our eyes sense light there are what is
light
they're a couple of different ways to
think about it one way to think about it
is it's a bunch of photons little
particles of light just like electrons
of particles of electricity photons or
particles of light that's kind of one
way to think about light another way to
think about light is it's an
electromagnetic wave we talked a little
bit before for people who are there when
I was talking about electric motors and
things we talked about how electricity
and magnetism are things that are
involved in electric motors here's a
here's a weird fact for you if if you if
you take an electric charge like an
electron and you wave it around you wave
it up and down the that waving of the
charge up and down will produce an
electromagnetic wave so it's just like
if you take a piece of string and you
wiggle the end of the piece of string
the piece of string will you'll see this
kind of wave going down a piece of
string well in the case of electricity
and magnetism if you take an electron
just has an electric charge and you
wiggle it around it will produce an
electromagnetic wave and that so you
might say well what's that
electromagnetic wave look like what's it
a wave in you know the wave on a piece
of string is a wave in the string people
were very confused about that 120 years
ago they thought there was a thing
called the ether which was the thing in
which electromagnetic waves exist and
turned out that wasn't quite right
although actually when we learn about
this new things I figured out in
fundamental physics they were actually
writer than they might have thought they
were but but let's not let's put that
aside but so electromagnetic waves are
waves that just propagate in the vacuum
and so when you wiggle an electron
around when you bring an electric charge
around it will produce an
electromagnetic wave that
electromagnetic wave to
on how fast you wiggle the electron
you'll get a different frequency of wave
so some frequencies of waves are make
radio waves and so when you if anybody
still ever does this if you tune in to a
radio station it'll say you know this is
99.7 megahertz or something and it will
and that means that the the electrons in
the antenna that make the radio wave
that is the radio wave associated with
that radio station they're being wiggled
up and down ninety-nine point seven
million times per second and that's
that's what produces an electromagnetic
wave of that frequency so one version of
a wave is what you get by wiggling
things let's say at that frequency if
you wiggle things even faster you get
different kinds of things produced so if
you wiggle things a trillion times a
second if you wiggle the the the charge
a trillion times a second you don't get
a radio wave you get light because light
is an electromagnetic wave that has a
higher frequency so the the sequence is
the lowest frequency is is radio waves
and different kinds of radio waves and
then you get to higher frequencies you
eventually get to infrared infrared
among other things is what heat radiant
heat is and then when you go even when
you go even faster even higher frequency
you get to visible light after that you
get to ultraviolet after ultraviolet you
get to x-rays then you get to gamma rays
um so that's one view of things as these
waves the other view is as photons and
each um you can think of this that's
kind of in quantum mechanics actually I
have recently figured out a great deal
about how this really works it's been
sort of confusing for the last hundred
years and I think I think it is now much
less confusing that that is a different
topic but in any case the photons are a
different view of electromagnetic stuff
it's they're little particles of
electromagnetic
activity and you can think about light
as being a stream of photons or an
electromagnetic wave you can think about
x-rays as being a stream of light as a
stream of photons higher energy photons
as as you go to higher frequencies from
radio waves to infrared to visible light
ultraviolet to x-rays that's a higher
frequency you're wiggling the electrons
faster and faster to make the waves that
also corresponds to higher energies of
photons so by the time you get to well
for things like gamma rays you can have
individual photons that each pack a
large amount of energy the so okay so
then the question is why can't we see
other forms of light well so other forms
of light the visible light is a
particular range of frequencies a
particular range of it's also a
particular range of wavelengths when you
think about the string you're wiggling
the string you see these waves and the
waves have a certain wavelength they had
their wiggles have a certain certain
length to them that's the so called
wavelength the relationship between the
frequency wiggle at and the wavelength
is determined by the speed of the waves
in the case of light it's the speed of
light um so in any case the for for
light the the Wiggles the wavelength so
typical light it's the red light is 500
nanometers so that's some let's see 10
to the minus some so that's 1/2 um all
right half a micron yeah so half a
millionth of a meter um is the
wavelength of so so different colors of
light correspond to slightly different
wavelengths like the different
frequencies slightly different energies
of photons it's actually the light that
we that our eyes see have a fairly
narrow range of frequencies
okay so so how does that work well the
the frequencies that we are kind of
tuned to be able to see with our eyes
pretty much correspond to the
frequencies that the Sun produces in
light and what here's another fact about
tum about sort of physics if you heat
something up it will gradually start
radiating photons radiating
electromagnetic radiation and you can
think about that a little bit as as you
heat it up
the electrons are wiggling around faster
and faster and they're making and
they're doing what I was describing
earlier happens in a radio antenna for
example they're producing
electromagnetic waves and as you wiggle
them around faster and faster by heating
the thing up more and more they generate
higher and higher frequency
electromagnetic waves so in for visible
light the lowest frequency
electromagnetic waves are red ones and
what happens is and so that's why when
you heat something up eventually it
first gets red hot as you can see
because it's just about making visible
light but it's only making red visible
light if you heat it up more than that
well I should say first of all that the
sequences it's like across a rainbow the
sequence goes from red through to blue
so red is the is the the longest
wavelength the lowest energy the lowest
frequency of light that we can see blue
is the highest frequency shortest
wavelength highest energy that we can
see and so as you heat something up at
first it doesn't produce any visible
light at all eventually it just is the
the the light that it the the
electromagnetic radiation it's producing
just about pokes into the visible you
can see a little bit of red light when
we heat it up more it gets into kind of
the to the point where it's it's
producing light of pretty much all
frequencies that we can see and that's
and that so it looks white-hot and so
that's that's around 6000 degrees I
think when things are 6000 degree
centigrade I think roughly you'll see
something where it's it's roughly
white-hot and produces all of the
frequencies that correspond to visible
right if you make it even hotter it's
most of the electromagnetic radiation
it's producing is higher energy higher
frequency than then corresponds to
visible light and you'll the last thing
you'll see is it'll look blue because
it's going off into the ultraviolet and
so on and it'll be blue hot so actually
if you're if you're interested in stars
our Sun is a star that is basically a
white star it's producing light that
goes across all the frequencies in our
visible light spectrum there are stars
some very small stars and some very big
stars that are red hot that have a that
produce light that are colder than the
Sun and produce and so produce light
that is more on the red side they're
also stars that are that are bluish
that a higher temperature than the Sun
but because our Sun happens it's surface
happens to be at about 6000 degrees
that's that produces electromagnetic
radiation that corresponds to this
particular range of frequencies that is
our white light so that's that's how the
light is produced now how do we see it
the way you see it is with our eyes and
with on our retina at the back of our
eyes so light goes into our eye and then
every every piece of light think about
it as an electromagnet wave think about
it as a photon let's think about it as a
photon every time when when we see we
see light what's happening is a stream
of photons are entering our eyes and
those photons hit the back of our eye
and they hit the the retina and on our
retina there's a particular molecule
that has the feature that when it
absorbs a photon of light it produces a
little electrical pulse and that
electrical pulse is transmitted to our
optic nerve and the optic nerve then
electrically transmits that to our
visual cortex at the back of our brain
it's kind of a piece of bad design that
the visual processing part of human
brains is at the back even though the
eyes are at the front so that means our
optic nerves have to go all the way
throughout through our brains to
get to the back where we can actually do
the processing but the way it works is
every photon that hits one of these
molecules in the in the on our retina
causes it to produce a little electrical
pulse and the way it works is that we
actually have four kinds of molecules on
in our eyes that two kinds of cells are
rod cells and our cone cells our rod
cells are sensitive to
essentially light intensity sort of see
in black and white and our cone cells
are sensitive to color we have three
kinds of cone cells red green roof ly
red green and blue cone cells that are
sensitive to roughly red green and blue
photons that are in the red green and
blue parts of the spectrum so when we
when we see light what's happening is
that a photon is going into our eye it's
hitting one of these cells on a retina
that's causing a little electrical pulse
that is going into our brains and then
we start synthesizing the image through
our visual cortex at the back of our
brain now it's sort of interesting that
we can it's sort of one photon per pulse
so you might ask well how many photons
do you need to actually see anything I
think the answer is about a thousand
photons you'll you'll start seeing stuff
I think that there are some of the the I
think king crabs or so the winners and I
think they can see individual photons
and actually they you know the the eye
that humans of the type that we have a
compound eye the the type that we have
which has a lens and a retina and so on
I think that's evolved like three times
and they in the history of life on earth
and we got one of the versions that's a
little bit goofy because we have a bunch
of essentially image processing
circuitry that is in front of where our
where our retina senses light which
seems like bad design I think the crabs
got it the other way around
um but in any case the so the the answer
to why we don't see why we only see
certain kinds of light is that the those
molecules in our retina are kind of
tuned to deal with only photons that the
way they they work they oh boy I can
explain that too but but um the way
those molecules were
they if they absorb a photon of a
certain frequency then they produce this
electrical pulse and it only works with
photons of that frequency so actually
the way that like this webcam that's
looking at me right now works it has a
CCD camera that actually works pretty
similar to the way a human eye works it
when a photon hits a little little thing
there instead of it being a piece of a
protein that um is the molecule it's a
it's a piece of a semiconductor and it
causes essentially an electron to get to
to get sort of emitted in the
semiconductor and that's the local pulse
that corresponds to one pixel of what
the camera sees alright next next
question here how feasible do you think
it is to create a computational model of
a biological organism gosh um well
certain aspects of biological organisms
we can do really pretty good job at you
know in in in my book new kind of
science I am I actually studied that
quite a bit let me show you something
here but some shares screen again and
let me see what I can pull up here hold
on one second
okay this is my big book that took me
ten years to write um
okay it has a section about biology and
so one thing that I show here is a bunch
of examples of kinds of structures that
kept produced in biology see if you can
identify some of these um Leo there's a
trilobite that's a creature from the
Cambrian actually that was that relates
to our previous question
trilobites they're great innovation was
eyes and light at the front of a
trilobite they were the first creatures
that had eyes that had actual them they
that they had they had a different type
of eye they had an eye I see now I'm
wondering whether I said the wrong thing
they had these little ommatidia which
are little instead of having a lens in
their eye they had something where they
just directly sense like a like they're
very close to being like an array of
pixels um anyway those were their big
innovation was eyes in the Cambrian
period I'm bill anyway these are just
different kinds of creatures those are
pollen grains things like that these are
things where there is a a structure that
you can see in this biological organism
and you might wonder is there kind of a
program that makes that structure like
there's there's a phyllotaxis spiral and
a daisy those are related to Fibonacci
numbers and so on one of the things that
I talk about a lot here see like I
should find a page sorry
um a lot of words here oh come now let's
see what I can do better
alright um let me look at Tim so the
question is can you can you find kind of
a a a model for how things work so this
is mollusk shells so you know you see
these mollusk shells and they all have
these spiral shapes and you see them and
there are lots of different shapes and
the question is could you make a program
that will make all those shapes of
mollusk shells and it's kind of fun to
look and you know depending on the exact
input to the program you'll get a
different shape of mollusk shell and one
day many years ago I am I had generated
all these different mollusk shell shapes
and I went to visit actually a big sign
a chiral history museum in Chicago and I
went to visit the person who was
responsible for mollusks there and I
said I've got all these different shapes
do you have mollusks that are each of
these shapes and he had about three
million different different specimens of
mollusks there and we spent a very
interesting afternoon trying to figure
out whether for all these shapes that my
model of what shapes you could possibly
get for shells did he have a mollusk
that had that particular shape and it's
kind of interesting because each mollusk
holdout he would say that mollusk is
that shape because and the you know
because well this mollusk is a very
pointy mollusk and it you know it is
that shape because it wedges itself in
rocks and that's how it works and this
mollusk is that shape because it gets
its food this way and so on and what was
interesting was that that yes those were
the ways that the mollusk could use
these shapes but it was clear that there
was sort of all possible shapes were
actually being produced somehow and then
these mollusks were kind of recruiting
those shapes for particular purposes
anyway so so there are these questions
cases where you can like see is there a
program for making is there a way of
understanding how the thing grows so an
another example would be there's another
example I was mentioning phyllotaxis so
if you're in if you're in a climate
where you have palm trees you go look at
a palm tree you will find out that there
are leafs cars going up the up the trunk
of the palm tree and they look pretty
much like this and they're always at a
particular angle 137 degrees if you go
measure it well you can prove me wrong
but but should be the case that they're
at about 137 degrees um and if you look
at a strawberry for example you'll find
that if you sort of took apart the
strawberry or pinecone
you'll find it's always you always get
this hundred and thirty seven degree
angle and that's an example of a place
where we do more or less understand why
there's a sort of very simple program
that kind of explains why that happens
and roughly the reason what's going on
is if you're a plant and you you're
growing a stem and you're going to put
up put a leaf out of the stem
put one of these leaves out then you
gonna put another leaf out well it'd be
really bad if all the leaves lined up
because if you want leaves to be out in
the Sun if all the leaves lined up the
leaf underneath is going to be in shadow
when when the Sun is in a particular
angle the leaf on top is going to it's
going to shade you so the smart thing to
do if you're a plant is to have your
leaves not be all in the same direction
so you might say well okay why don't we
just have the leaves be opposite one
leaf comes out here another leaf comes
out the opposite the 180 degrees away
well that's not optimal because then by
the time you've got your two leaves up
you've got your second leaf is
interfering with your third leaf is
interfering with your first leaf and so
on so it turns out there is an optimal
angle to make your leaves come out out
and that angle is 137 degrees and that
angle is it's related to the golden
ratio in radians for people who are into
the math of that um and and we can
actually understand you know we actually
know why why it works that way in terms
of how the plant the plant has has
chemicals in it
that um and the the way the reactions
between the reaction and the fusion
between these chemicals work sort of
produces this result 137 degrees but to
the plant it's a good deal because it
means that it believes minimally shade
each other but so there are things like
that that we can do to understand how
organisms work now a question you might
ask is given that we know the DNA of the
organism can we just compute how the
organism is going to work
could we just figure out for our six
billion base pairs for a human could we
just run a program that says we got that
input is our six billion base pair
program we just run it run it run it and
compute what is the organism going to do
well it isn't as easy as that
because there's a there's a nasty thing
that happens which i think is a very
lovely thing actually but it's a science
phenomenon that I had kind of discovered
years ago let me just show you I've got
a I got to run some code here um so this
is an example let me show you this see
um
this is going to be there's a very very
very simple program so there's a program
where all the program does is it just
has a row of black and white cells and
you can do this yourself you can get a
piece of people don't make graph paper
anymore a piece of squared paper with
bunch of squares on it and you can just
you can do this yourself and it this is
a rule that says if you have two white
squares and a black square - it's right
then underneath you put down a black
square okay and and you just follow this
rule over and over and over again so
let's try running that particular rule
um I can just run it and let's just
start it off with one black square at
the top and let's run that rule 30 times
and I'm gonna show a mesh here okay so
that's just taking that rule that I had
at the top and it's just running it 30
times so we can kind of look at how this
works so there's a black square there
it's surrounded by two white squares so
we go look up here it says black square
surrounded by two white squares make a
white square so that's why it does that
let's look at this one here that's white
square white square black square so
let's go look that up white square white
square black square it says make a black
square so that's why that's a black
square there so this is just following a
rule that just says follow this rule and
see what pattern you get okay let's try
a different rule here um let's try it so
it's a slightly different choice of what
of how it's set up
run that rule we get this pattern here
okay so that's a little bit more
complicated let's run that pattern a
little bit longer let's get rid of the
mesh because we don't need that anymore
um and that's the pattern that you get
so you'll see it's a nested pattern is
really cool is a often called sierpinski
patterns or fractal patterns is a type
of fractal pattern you can you can draw
these yourself just just with triangles
um they're a cool thing to draw um and
or you can you can make the pattern by
just following this rule on a thing with
squares of papers or squares on paper
okay so you might have said okay if we
have a really simple rule like this we
can figure out what it's going to do
we just we can just look at the rule and
if we were clever with math and all that
kind of thing we could just figure out
what's gonna do in the case of this
particular rule for people who know
fancier stuff this is basically making
Pascal's triangle mod 2 and it's
possible to see why that does what it
does ok let me show you another rule so
it's gonna be the same type of rule but
slightly different details for how it
works
ok this is my all-time favorite science
discovery so I have to get excited about
it um run this rule and that's what you
get isn't that super weird so you know
it's a really simple rule but yet the
behavior you get looks really random and
like if you look down is it you can see
some regularity you can see it's got
some regularity over on the Left it's
got these little triangles it makes but
like if you just look down the center
here you go black white black you know
you'll see some sequence of blacks and
whites and if I just showed you that
sequence you just say that's completely
random you'd never guess that it was
made from a rule it's this simple and so
that's really a remarkable phenomenon
for people who know math you kinds of
things like come there's a sort of a
some analogs of that like pi let's work
out the ratio of the diameter to the
circumference to the diameter of a
circle you know people may know it's
3.14159 etc etc etc that sequence of
digits is kind of hard to remember
because it's really random looking um
and it is so far as people can tell
really a random sequence
um and it's like even though there was a
rule for making it once you made it the
sequence seems completely random and
it's like um and this is an example
where there's an even much simpler rule
and once you given the rule once you
actually start generating things from it
it's really hard to predict what's gonna
happen and we can make a computer run
you can just run a computer and find out
what happens but if we want to just sit
and think and just you know write down a
math formula or something we won't be
able to do that in this case and so the
same thing happens in biology all over
the place I think and I think a lot of
what's going on in biology is this kind
of irreducible computation you can't
figure out what's going to happen except
effectively by just running it and
seeing what happens and so that's one of
the issues in in making kind of in
figuring out
it's gonna happen in biology so you know
like they're a bad cases in biology like
for example tumors where cells grow
that's what happens in cancer and so on
normally our cells
you know once they've grown once they've
replicated a certain number of times
maybe 50 times or something they just
stop replicating they don't grow anymore
but um when things go wrong they can
just keep growing and so you can ask the
question you know given a particular
cell is it going to keep growing forever
or is it which would be bad and in our
case or is it going to stop the way it's
supposed to stop well let me show you an
example with one of these rules show you
one here um that um different rules same
same general idea it's to rule 110 let's
run that so this particular rule has the
feature that it grows only on the left
so my diagram is only going to only
going to show it going on the left it
wouldn't it wouldn't doesn't go on the
right so let's run it for like um 800
steps okay so after 800 steps you see
these weird little structures that are
being produced later on if we were
talking about physics we might actually
think about those structures as being a
little bit like things like electrons
and so on but that's for another day
um but okay so we have these little
structures and you might ask the
question are these structures ever going
to die out you know in this particular
thing it's made a few of these
structures are they ever going to die
out well we could just run the thing and
see what happens but if we want to
predict are they were going to go out
that's really hard okay so I ran it for
2,000 steps and still it's not
completely clear what happens because
I've done this before I know that after
like I think it's 2,600 steps and I
still didn't happen I'm wrong I didn't
remember correctly
let's try 3,500 steps um okay eventually
if you can see it it's probably a little
bit small on the screen this particular
structure dies out but it took we had to
run the thing for 3,000 steps to find
out what was going to happen and that's
the kind of thing that can happen in
biology if you try to even if you know
the rule that made the biological
organism working out what the actual
organism will produce
is can be really hard and and you know
biology you know we when we make
computers we make them out of things
like silicone we etc etc etc and these
days oh like every bit in our computers
is maybe I don't know 10 to 100 thousand
electrons or something per bit um
biology actually sort of does computing
at a molecular scale it's the only
technology in the sense is not
technology because we didn't we didn't
make it but biology is a place where
ones effectively doing computing but at
the level of molecules and we're slowly
learning how to do that we're not quite
there yet but biology is kind of an
example of where computing like things
are happening but with molecules alright
let me go back to I think I I digress a
little bit long on that let me see this
um alright let me go back here
lots
lots of fascinating things here sorry
how do you recommend students with a
solid calculus background learn physics
and mathematics hmm that's complicated
because it really depends you know both
physics and mathematics are big fields
so it kind of depends a little bit what
aspects of it you want to learn I mean
if you want to learn you know
mathematics I don't have a great answer
for that actually I mean I think that um
there's oh I can start recommending if
you if you want to learn sort of
fundamental physics and things and you
really know calculus well one example
well I mean there are some books that
have sort of some mathy kinds of things
in them my friend Roger Penrose wrote a
book called the road to reality which i
think is a I'm not sure it actually has
any leadership because it has sort of a
mixture of very interesting intuitive
stuff and complicated math but if you
really understand calculus well it might
be an interesting book to look at about
fundamental physics the I don't I don't
know I mean I would say my general
comment is I mean for me learning things
okay so for me actually being able to
write a program in Wolfram language to
make a sort of computational
representation of what I'm thinking
about is really important so you know
for me that's the way I like to
understand things and it's kind of like
understanding things by writing on a
math formula is one form of
understanding it's kind of using math as
a language for understanding what's
going on one of the things I've tried to
do over the last 30 years I've been
building both languages to make a
language where you can kind of
understand things computationally in the
same way that we sort of understand
things mathematically when we write down
math notation this is kind of a
computational language is sort of a
notation for understanding things
computationally and that's a super good
way to once you have that kind of
computational understanding then you
really understand things and not only
that you can impact us two computations
with it so
in the work I've been doing on
fundamental physics the things that we
figured out would absolutely been
impossible if we hadn't been able to
sort of actualize them by actually
writing pieces of code so that's a
that's a partial answer to that um okay
so there's another question about um
about Alive and death and proteins let's
skip that because I think I already
addressed that okay what career advice
would you recommend for an engineer stay
in industry start an engineering
education based company it's really
specific to different people I mean I
think one of the things that's always
interesting you know I have sort of a
meta theory about careers and life and
so on and it's that sort of everybody
has kind of an optimal thing that they
could be doing maybe there's several
optimal things that they could be doing
sometimes it's hard to find that optimal
thing and what you learn in school is
just you know you learn math you learn
science you learn writing learn a bunch
of things that are our basic skills that
are pretty useful but um you know you
don't necessarily get exposed to all the
things that are actually what different
people in the world do and worse than
that the things that are most relevant
if you're a kid the things that are
going to be a you know the careers of
the future barely exists today and it's
it's always kind of interesting you know
I've been involved in various fields
that have kind of started up and it's
always been interesting to see that
people get into those fields really
early have a really good time so if you
if you are in you know if you're the
first person who's doing social media
stuff or if you're the first person
who's doing some particular kind of
thing with computational thinking or
something that's um that's a really good
deal so in slightly more advanced stuff
my heuristic for figuring out where
things are going to go is imagine a
field X it might be archaeology it might
be zoology might be almost anything and
call that field call that field X then
there either is now a computational X or
there will be so you know there isn't
now much of a computational archaeology
but there will be
and any so if you want to get into
something that is sort of at the
beginning of it a computational field
computational X is a really good thing
so pick something you're interested in
learning up about computation to be able
to apply it to that field and likely
you'll be one of the early people in
that field now there are some areas of
computation which are better developed
computational biology computational
linguistics those are a little bit
better developed than computational
zoology for example which really isn't
developed much at all um and you know
what what is computational zoology like
for example a long-running question I I
was showing you pictures of mollusk
shells so one thing you might think of
so zoology is in the studies of critters
creatures animals etc one thing you
might say is sort of a piece of
computational zoology might be what are
all the possible shapes of shells in the
world and how do we think about that as
a sort of computer kind of thing or one
that I've been really interested in what
are all the possible shapes of leaves in
the world there are all these different
shapes of leaves some leaves are very
smooth some leaves are very that have
lots of pointy pieces on them there is
no theory for the different possible
shapes of leaves I mean I have a
possible theory but we don't know if
it's true because we've never really
made a systematic collection of all the
different possible shapes of leaves but
that would be an example of well that
would be computational botany rather
than computational zoology but it's the
same kind of idea and each one of these
things in the case of you know
computational botany it might be you
know having a machine learning automated
recognition of these things or lots of
different kinds of things you could do
with computers there but that sort of
getting into these things early is is
really a great kind of career strategy I
think I mean the only issue is if you're
too too early in the field you sometimes
have to you know do a bunch of
explaining to anybody else why they
should care about that field you know
it's if you're if you're like the first
person during some particular kind of
field it's like hey world you know this
is really interesting
um and you know that's a slightly
different kind of situation than being
in a field where it's really really
popular and they're like ten thousand
people working on the same thing and if
you do something really clever people
immediately say
oh I know that's a real problem that's
really what you've done is really clever
so it's a slightly different
optimization but I think that it's a you
know different people have different um
different skill sets and so and it's
also worth remembering that some of the
things that are kind of selected for in
school aren't necessarily the things
that are relevant and selected for in in
careers that you might have I mean I
think you know some kids who are always
like bouncing up and down and jumping
around and and you know having a hard
time focusing on one thing for long
enough to do stuff that they do in
school well turns out there are a bunch
of professions where that trait is like
really really useful I mean I think if
you're going to be a you know quite how
true this is these days but if you're
going to be a trader and you know
financial markets trader and things the
jumping up and down and doing things
very quickly is is like a really useful
trait even though it may be a negative
you know for being in a school classroom
it's a positive if you're a trader you
know trading trading stocks really fast
or something and I think it's true you
know sometimes I get kind of frustrated
because you know when when you do sort
of when you do work in in a career or
something you know doing things exactly
right is often really really important
it's not a question of oh let's do it
you know within the time available and
we'll get partial credit it's like no
you actually have to get it right you
know if you're writing computer programs
and you know you're working a software
engineer or something and you're like
well I got you know I should get partial
credit the program almost worked it's
kind of like no that doesn't really work
out that way and I think it's sometimes
a bit of a bad thing that people are
like in school they're like well you
know I'm going to do this because I'm
gonna do it really fast and I'm going to
do it only to a certain level I think
it's some I mean I I might just make my
little pitch for learn the stuff you
wanna learn because you know you'll
remember that stuff and you know doing a
bunch of things where oh I'm doing this
because I need to do that because I'm
gonna get this credential because of
this and that and the other I you know
the stuff that'll really stay with you
is the stuff you really wanted to learn
I mean I've been lucky enough I have a
pretty decent memory and I you know I
remember the stuff that I learned when I
was in
all including a lot of fun biology stuff
where I was mentioning earlier you know
red blood cells white blood cells but
they're a bunch of things where I learnt
you know I remember the golgi complex is
an organelle in cells and the thing that
I memorized is the Golgi complex is an
organelle of unknown function which of
course its function is now well known
you know whatever it is 50 years later
or something
um but the I mean one thing I might say
about my education was I learnt things
like Latin and Greek okay and I was
complaining like crazy it's like why am
i learning this stuff I'll never use it
blah blah blah well if I reach behind me
I would find on my shelf there a Latin
dictionary in a Greek dictionary how can
that be I would never lose the stuff
well the answer is because I'm involved
in like making up names for things like
products and ideas and science and so on
I with great frequency end up you know
turning to the Latin Greek dictionaries
to try and see what inspiration I can
get for words there so it's kind of like
you never know what you're going to find
useful in the end but I must say that
that um learning things that you like to
learn is really really worthwhile and
sort of knowing about things that are
kind of beyond another thing to
understand is sometimes people well I
was going to say knowing about things
that are sort of beyond the specific
subjects that get taught in school is is
really nice because those are the things
that you know many there are many other
things that are things that you might
make a career out of and you might get
really excited about and maybe you could
backtrack from knowing I really want to
be a such and such therefore I should
learn about this and that and the other
thing like I when I was a kid I really
wanted to be a physicist I was lucky
enough to actually be a physicist very
early in my life and went on to do other
things after that although I'm now sort
of coming back to doing physics but
that's different story um but you know
so backtracking from that well I need
you to learn a bunch of math I need to
learn a bunch of this and that and the
other as I said I may be create a bad
example there because when I was
learning a bunch of math I found some of
the mechanical aspects kind of dull and
that's why I ended up using computers
and building tools to do math with
computers and so on
but I was some yeah I think that was all
I was going to say there okay I see a
question from a Henry why does space
never end
okay good question complicated question
okay let me give you an example that
doesn't really apply to us but let's
imagine that you were an ant who just
lived on a on a table flat table and all
you know is you're an ant walking around
on this table you never get to climb up
anything you just get you just on this
table and the ant could go it goes that
goes it goes along and eventually oops
it reaches the edge of the table okay
its space has kind of ended there it's
reached the edge of the table but now
imagine that your aunt was living on a
sphere maybe living on a little tiny
asteroid that was so the ant is is
crawling around that's crawling around
on the sphere and the ants like the ant
crawling around on the table it's just
moving on this on this thing that is
just two-dimensional it's it's just on
the surface and it's crawling around
crawling around it's like am I ever
gonna reach the edge oh I've got a
theory you know there's an edge to space
but I just keep crawling I keep calling
but I can as I go on the sphere I never
reached the edge instead what happens is
I come back to the beginning again so
that's kind of how in a sense how you
might imagine that you could end up with
something like space that doesn't have
an end is that you could have something
where as you sort of crawl around it you
you just come back where you started
from now in our space we're not we're
not living in this kind of plane in this
two-dimensional thing we're living in
three dimensions of space but you could
actually have something in principle you
can have something where our three
dimensionals of space are all curled
around and they come back and they they
come back like a torus like a doughnut
they accept a doughnut where it's a
three-dimensional doughnut so
because actually it's a bad example I
really should be talking about kind of a
a an analog of my sphere where instead
of having a two-dimensional surface I
have a three-dimensional surface on a
four dimensional sphere on a sphere in
four dimensions it's a little hard to
visualize but okay so what happens in
our actual universe is that how our
actual universe works we don't know for
sure but it's probably not how our
actual universe works instead one of the
things that happens in our actual
universe is imagine that we were going
to go visit the outer reaches of our
universe we have a spacecraft we're
going there going along and you may know
that the universe is expanding so the
universe expands and so you know it
started about 14 billion 15 billion
years ago now started very small and for
reasons that we don't understand
although this theory of mine now has
some beginnings of an understanding of
that the universe just had this big bang
event and just started expanding and it
started expanding actually expanded
really fast probably at first it
expanded almost paradoxically it
expanded faster than speed of light the
current favorite theory for the initial
expansion of the universe involves early
expansion that was faster than the speed
of light um and although no no signals
inside the universe travel faster than
speed of light the actual edges of the
universe effectively travel faster than
the speed of light but anyway the
universe is traveling outwards and it's
expanding since bannings expanding okay
so let's imagine we want to reach the
edge of the universe so to speak well
the problem is that in our spacecraft
we're going out to the edge of the
universe but as we go out towards the
edge of universe the universe is
expanding and so in a sense by the time
we would have reached because the
universe is expanding well roughly at
the speed of light and our spacecraft
can't go that fast by the time we would
have gotten to the edge of universe the
universe would have already expanded
away from us now I'm cheating a bit in
that explanation for people who are
really understanding this is a little
tricky and the best way to do it is by
drawing diagrams in which you look at in
space versus time you look at
essentially the the set of of how how
one effect in the universe can cause
another effect in the universe but
roughly roughly these these two things
sort of on the one side the the kind of
you keep going around the sphere you'll
never reach the edge and the other if
the thing is expanding you it's by the
time you would have gotten to where it
got to it would have already expanded
further between those two things
I'm giving you a a reasonable
approximation to what one actually knows
from the physics of what goes on ah okay
why does so many old technical
institutions insist on manual
calculation rather than taking advantage
of modern computational tools I think a
large part of that is because it's kind
of easier to tell whether somebody could
do something by seeing did they do they
mechanically work out some particular
computation now having said that
learning to do something precisely is
really worthwhile I mean if you you know
it's it's super useful to have kind of
the the discipline of knowing how to
work something out and actually get the
right answer I mean I would claim that
writing programs is a very satisfying
way to do that because unlike something
when you do a big piece of algebra and
then the teacher tells you you've got
the wrong answer if you're writing a
piece of code you write piece of code
and if you get it right you press shift
enter if it's worth language stuff it
runs and it either produces a beautiful
picture or it sticks its tongue out at
you metaphorically and says um you know
you you did this wrong and but you get
to correct it and you get to be
interacting with the computer and
eventually when you've told the computer
the right thing the computer says okay I
got it
and it produces some great answer and
that's very satisfying but knowing how
to do something precisely is really an
important thing and the
you know I think that's really
worthwhile and you know math is one way
to to learn that I think programming is
another way to learn that um okay the
next question is a rather advanced one
commenting that is about working out the
one plus one equals two which which
hopefully pretty much every kid who's
watching this knows that one plus one is
equal to two but if you want to prove
that so what's mentioned here is it took
three hundred pages or something in this
book called principia mathematica to
prove that one plus one equals two okay
let me just explain a little bit about
that so when you set up math you learn
to do computations like you can count on
your fingers one two okay that's two you
know one two three four okay we got to
you know you know two plus two is four
we can count that on our fingers we can
do these calculations all works just
fine and that's what we can do a lot of
math we can do that way when we get to
really fancy math and particularly math
that involves infinity we can't do it
that way because we don't have an
infinite number of fingers and if
somebody cell asks you what is 1 divided
by infinity okay
you can't count that on your fingers you
have to have some other way to work out
that 1 divided by infinity there's
actually 0 but you have to have some
other way to work out things like that
involve infinity and so there's this
idea in math that says you can work it
out by essentially following rules and
seeing what rules what the consequences
of those rules are and so the way that
happens is it was originally the
earliest version of this was a guy
called you cleared back in in ancient
Greek times set it up for geometry he
set up these axioms that say make
statements like new no two parallel
lines ever cross if you have two lines
that are parallel they'll never cross if
you have a triangle it will that's
another good example of an axiom of you
played another axiom is if you have two
points they
which is an axiom I'm forgetting my
axioms but two points to find a line or
three points or what you need to define
a plane in three-dimensional space but
so Euclid set up these axioms of things
that he kind were always true about
geometry and then what happens is a lot
of what mathematicians do is they
essentially take axioms they don't
always think about themselves as doing
it exactly this way but what they're
effectively doing is taking axioms and
proving from those axioms what's true so
for example that's what happens in logic
so very famous kind of I don't know of
famous some I don't know we can we can
make up a piece of logic I don't know we
can say
[Music]
let's see um all
cheaper white and
that's a good example of this well
here's a piece of bad logic all sheep
are white my dog is white
therefore my dog is a sheep okay bad
piece of logic incorrect inference from
from the statements but when we get a
correct set of inferences so for example
if you say all sheep are white and then
you say Billie is black you can say
therefore Billie is not a sheep and if
you've set up the axioms for logic
correctly you'll be able to make that
conclusion and so in in if we if we do
that so if we set things up in in so in
mathematics we can set up these axioms
that say what's true for example what's
true about numbers so for example one
axiom of arithmetic is that a plus B is
the same as B plus a so if we say what's
two plus three it's the same of what as
what's three plus two but that's true
whatever you fill in for the three and
two it could be infinity plus something
else if that thing represents a number
it's always true that a plus B is equal
to B plus a and so if we have those
axioms then we can essentially in
principle we can prove anything that's
true in mathematics and sometimes when
you go from the axioms to figuring out
what's true it can be a really hard job
to go from the axioms to working out
what's true is you have to kind of
arrange these axioms in just the right
way to to get to the true fact that
you're trying to prove actually one of
the one of the terrible things that was
discovered in mathematics in the 1930s
is that it doesn't always work that
there are things in mathematics where
you can say this is the thing but you
can never find a proof or disproof of
whether it's true and it's actually a
little bit related to that thing I
showed you earlier about will this
particular pattern ever die out or not
in mathematics you could ask the
question after an infinite time what
does this do and it may turn out you
just can't answer that without doing an
infinite amount of work
it's a thing called girdles theorem in
mathematics but um so this particular
book written in 1910 I think that was
kind of made fun of and deservedly so
for the fact that it took 300 pages to
prove that one plus one equals two they
were trying to prove that from the
axioms from axioms of mathematics and
logic it was kind of a goofy exercise
actually now I might say that these
axioms in a sense in physics in
mathematics we have accents you just
write down things we'd say things like
no two parallel lines can have a cross
well actually think about that statement
no two parallel lines can have a cross
on a sphere you can it doesn't quite
work that way
and one of the big questions that came
up one of the things that Einstein
discovered in 1915 was that it's not
true a physical space that no two
parallel lines can ever cross so for
example if you shoot a laser out in in
space the laser will will follow a
perfect straight line that piece of
laser light will just go in a perfect
straight line but a straight line in a
certain definition of a straight line
but it turns out that if that laser was
going around well in the most extreme
case it was going around a black hole
but even going around the Sun um that
laser will actually that the light will
actually be bent going around that
object and the reason that happens is
it's still going on a straight line but
that straight line is because space is
curved a phenomenon that was what
Einstein sort of discovered in 1915 that
space is intrinsically curved that means
that even though the laser is really
going in a straight line it's going a
straight line on this curved thing and
so when we look at it so from the
outside it seems curved and if you look
at for example two parallel lines two
parallel pieces of laser light on
opposite sides of the Sun or opposite
sides of a black hole they'll actually
cross over and that's a phenomenon
called gravitational lensing that's
actually observed and so it's not true
in physical space the axiom that Euclid
had that two parallel lines never cross
isn't true in physical space
that sort of the difference between
physics which is something where you
just sort of observed things in the
world and mathematics we just said this
is what's really true and actually in my
theory of physics we which we'll discuss
another time it gets a little closer to
to that okay let's see um
I mean I'm gonna skip ahead a little bit
because we've got a lot of questions
here and sort of spending a lot of time
let's see um
let's do this one how do you determine
if a planet is sustainable for human
life like an exoplanet it's an
interesting question so so first of all
you know when I was a kid we knew there
were planets in our solar system but we
didn't know if there were any planets
going around other stars and we thought
maybe we were really rare in having a
bunch of planets in our solar system
turns out we're not rare at all a lot of
stars perhaps even most stars have
planets around them when we now know
thousands of stars that have exoplanets
um and we and even for example people
always used to say or it's really
coincidence that our solar system has
what was in those days nine planets now
we only count eight planets actually for
a star of the size of our Sun it's
actually very typical that we'll end up
with about that number of planets
probably and actually probably in the
early history of our solar system we may
have had more planets we may have had
fewer planets probably we had more
planets and planets crashed into each
other maybe that's how the asteroid belt
happened maybe not or planets were
pulled out and ripped out of our solar
system maybe by passing other star maybe
their other star captured one of our
planets maybe there's a poor planet
that's floating in interstellar space
without a star to go around we don't
know for sure but it's sort of a natural
selection like it like happens in
biology it's like if you're a planet in
a very stable orbit you'll keep going
around your star if there's something
wrong with your orbit you might get
ripped out of orbit around around that
star um and so so anyway we know that
there are planets around many other
stars and
ways that we've detected those planets
there are a couple of different ways we
detect those planets one of them is by
watching for the light of the star to be
dimmed because a planet went in front of
the star that's good for really big
planets we can look at wobbles in the in
the position of the star because of the
motion of the planets things like that
and there are other methods of detection
that detect planets of different sizes
and different distances from stars and
so on so we we don't know about sort of
all the planets because we have only
certain methods of detection and they
are not sensitive to all planets but we
have some idea what what time what
planets are out there so the next
question is how can we tell what's what
what those planets are like so one thing
we'd like to know is what are the
atmospheres of those planets like well
how on earth would you tell that these
planets might be you know 10 light years
away from us they're far far away you
know that the farthest any human created
thing has gone is how far is it maybe a
hundred times the distance from the
Earth Sun maybe 200 times but this since
the nearest star is much greater than
that and I have to go ask wolf now for
what it is because I I don't know in
astronomical units let's see what it is
for light-years in astronomical units
and I will tell you what the answer is
it is 250,000 astronomical units so the
nearest star is 250,000 times the
distance between the the Earth and the
Sun um so so our spacecraft haven't got
even close to that far so how it off can
we tell what the atmosphere of a planet
orbiting another star is well here's how
we can tell when when light so our
atmosphere looks slightly blue you know
when we look at the sky it looks blue it
looks blue as a result of a thing called
Rayleigh scattering
I'm cheating a little bit to say that
the the the blueness of our sky will be
true regardless of what our atmosphere
is made of but there are other things
about essentially the color of light
that gets through our atmosphere and so
on that does depend on what what gases
are in an atmosphere like our particular
atmosphere is roughly 80% nitrogen 20%
oxygen and there are things where what
light gets through depends on which
gases were there and that happens and
it's the simplest case of this um
fluorescent lights or an example where
you can see the phenomenon that
different different gases different
different atoms okay so so roughly what
happens you know there is there are
about a hundred kinds of atoms those are
the things in the periodic table
hydrogen helium lithium beryllium boron
and so on each one of those elements is
a different kind of atom is an atom
which has a different number of protons
in its nucleus and a different sort of
number of electrons when it's an
ordinary atom and each one of those
atoms that when photons have talked
about those earlier when light when when
one of those atoms absorbs a photon of
light the the way that its electrons
respond to that is characteristically
different and different different kinds
of atoms will absorb photons will will
absorb light of different colors will
emit light of different colors and so on
and that's and so using that phenomenon
you can where if you see light for
example coming from a star and it goes
through the atmosphere of planet then
you can tell by what how the light
changes as a result of going through the
atmosphere of the planet you can get an
idea of what the what the gases in the
atmosphere of the planet are and so you
could for example tell whether there's
oxygen and they in the atmosphere of the
of that pilot now there's a difficult
thing to do and once just on the edge of
beginning to be able to do that for
exoplanets so we don't yet know
that we can calculate if we knew stuff
about the atmosphere of the planet and
we know how far away the the planet is
from its star we could get an idea how
hot the surface of the planet is likely
to be whether liquid water can exist
there all those kinds of things and that
gives us some idea of whether whether
one could support life of the kind that
we know now one of the tricky things
there is what is life you know people
were asking questions about viruses are
they alive you know what is the abstract
definition of life see the thing is we
only have we only have one example of
life which is life on Earth and all life
on Earth is ultimately descended from
the same the same organisms we all have
we all share ancestry with all life on
Earth and that means that for example
RNA and basically DNA the molecule that
you know records the the genetic program
of organisms every all life on Earth
cher has RNA it all uses RNA molecules
it all uses amino acids and proteins and
things like that it all uses the same
chemistry all life on Earth uses those
same kinds of ideas same same kinds of
kinds of actual chemicals and so on and
so what happens so we only have this one
example of life so if we want to know is
there life somewhere else we have to
kind of generalize our definition of
life now we could say is there life just
like life on Earth on other planets and
that's a reasonable question to ask and
we could go and and if we do find let's
say we found life on I don't know Europa
or something or or life even under the
in the you know in the ice caps of Mars
or something and if we found life there
and the life was really really similar
to life on Earth
what would we conclude will we conclude
that those forms of life have separately
evolved but we we conclude that let's
say a comet coming through the solar
system
had sort of separately had had been the
original source and had seeded this
identical life from these two different
to different planets for example I'm not
sure I think it's more likely that it
would have been seeded by one thing than
that
evolved in the exact same way in two
different places but if we try to
generalize the definition of what is
life it's kind of tricky I mean so what
is life you know what what counts as
something being alive where you can say
for example oh I don't know for example
in ancient Greek times people had a
definition of things being alive and it
was things that can move themselves
where there's no external force that
seems to be needed to move it but you
know we have plenty of things from steam
engines on these days that move
themselves so that's not a really good
definition of life another definition
might be things that can replicate
themselves well we have plenty of
definitions whether it's computer
programs that are you know like like
malicious worms and the internet or
whether it's some whether it's other
kinds of things that are not or not
don't meet aren't like life on Earth but
they still can reproduce themselves so
even the self reproduction thing is not
a really convincing definition of life
we don't really know what the abstract
definition of life is and I think when
we you know if we ever go get to see
what's happening on exoplanets and we
see all kinds of weird things going on
there we might have a big argument about
is that life or is it not life I think
that um you know when I was a kid was
when the first space probes were landing
on on Mars and there was a big question
how could they tell whether there was
life on Mars and you know you could look
around you could see are there a bunch
of plants growing there okay that's an
easy test but then they had tests and
they're one of the favorite tests was
you scoop up a bunch of soil from the
Martian surface you feed it sugar and
you see if it metabolizes in other words
you know in a sense does does Martian
life like candy then it's alive um well
needless to say didn't actually work for
for Martian soil but that's a really
weird test for life is you know does
life like sugar you know that's a test
for whether it's alive and there were
some other tests that were proposed but
but they're all very specific to life on
Earth so we don't really have a good
abstract test and that means it's really
hard to answer the question what's it
going to take to support life and
it's even you know the other thing that
comes up often is you know intelligence
you know what's it gonna take to make
you know extraterrestrial intelligence
and so on that's an even more
complicated thing to answer um and one
of the things one of the stories I like
to tell about Mars actually is back
around around when radio was first being
invented in the late 1800s Early 1900s
the people would particularly a guy
called Marconi who was involved in early
radio and also Tesla who's now famous
because Elon Musk put his name on a car
that Nikola Tesla was another person
involved in early radio the they were
they were listening so this was before
there were radio stations and so but
they could detect radio waves and
particularly Marconi actually had a
yacht that he used to travel across the
Atlantic and and in the middle of the
Atlantic
you know his radio mast will be picking
up radio signals and they would be
making weird noises and things that he
could could play and the question was
what on earth was that because there
were no radio stations there is the
middle of the Atlantic there's nothing
you know well actually shortwave radio
could could have a long way radio could
have could have reached there but let's
say it let's ignore that first
approximation no human radio stations so
so Tesla was a little bit more into
making wild theories said I know what
that is that's the Martians signaling us
using radio and that's that's what those
radio transmissions are turns out there
wasn't true turns out the radio
transmissions actually are the result of
magnetic magneto hydrodynamic processes
in the Earth's ionosphere so they're a
result of actually I was mentioning this
that electrons moving around produced
electromagnetic waves that happens in
the Earth's atmosphere and the upper
atmosphere and the so there's radio
produced in the in the upper atmosphere
of the earth that used to cause trouble
back when people back when I was a kid
when people had long range long wave
radio where you could like listen to
radio stations from the other side of
the earth
certain times of day because the radio
waves would bounce off the ionosphere
that was it was important there were
there was sort of radio generated by
that um but anyway so it's a complicated
question what um how you tell whether
something is intelligent were those were
those radio emissions intelligent or not
they are bizarrely similar if you if you
listen to those actual sounds that
bizarre is similar to whale song sounds
which which makes it even more confusing
alright let's see um
how does science give us answers
I think that's too complicated a
question there's too much to say about
that um as question here how did the
earth evolve okay I can try taking that
one um okay so back so first question is
how did the Sun evolve and even how did
the galaxy evolve okay so back in the
very early universe the the universe
started from this Big Bang this very
small clump of of stuff is very hot kind
of explodes out in this in this giant
expansion that has been going on ever
since as the universe cooled down as it
expanded slowly lumps of of stuff
started to so started to form as a
result of gravity so gravity pulls
things together just like it it pulls
you know if you throw something up the
the gravity associated with the earth
will pull it back down again gravity is
what pulls the earth towards the Sun and
keeps it in its orbit any time something
has mass you can see that something has
mass by the fact that has inertia you
need to put a force you need to push it
with a force in order to get it to start
to move one of the one of the
fascinating facts in science is that the
mass associated with inertia is the same
as the mass associated with generating
gravity but whenever something has a
mass it will produce some gravity so so
like we have a mass if if we were out in
space and everything else was we didn't
have anything else going on we would
produce a certain amount of gravity and
we would attract things to us just
through the force of gravity so anything
with mass produces gravity and things
that have mass and things that gravity
will pull things together so in the very
early universe um the things started
coming together and you started getting
kind of lumps of mass people don't
actually know exactly how that worked if
the universe started really really
really uniform it's very hard to see
whoever gets to make the clump first
it's really it's like the universe was
perfectly smooth perfectly it's like
where would the thing ever comp because
it's all smooth so why would it ever
make a clump people don't know the
answer to that actually this physics
work that I've been doing recently
provides a new answer to that question
of how the early fancy words density
perturbations occurred in the universe
but in any case so what what started to
happen was in the very early universe
within I don't know the first well by
the time a hundred thousand years after
the beginning of the universe there were
already clumps that were forming in the
universe already places where there were
higher densities of gas than other
places okay so as the force of gravity
makes those clumps get more and more
clumpy and as those clumps got more and
more and more company eventually they
started to form into galaxies and the
the galaxies there are now about a
hundred billion galaxies in our in our
universe and those formed fairly early
in the history of the universe some
later than others within those galaxies
the the galaxies so they have different
kinds of galaxies but like our galaxy is
a spiral galaxy that's spinning around
but you form this this all this gas in
the in the galaxies and it's it slowly
starts to form also into stars again
because of gravity and in our in our
galaxy which is a pretty large galaxy we
have a hundred billion stars and each
one of those came by by gas that was
being attracted by gravity forming
together and eventually it gets to the
point where it's like being pulled
pulled pulled together and eventually it
it forms this this area that's a big
lump of higher density gas okay so what
happens when this big lump of high
density gas eventually it lights up as a
star and in fact in general it's true
that when you have a big lump of if you
have enough stuff together the force of
gravity is strong enough that it will
cause the atoms in in the material to
get so close the nuclei of the atoms get
so close that they fuse together and
that produces a large amount of energy
it's the same phenomenon at
that happens in hydrogen bombs also
happens inside stars that term but
basically whenever the force of gravity
is strong enough it will make the
hydrogen gas for example will push the
hydrogen gas together
with such force at such high pressure
that eventually the nuclei the hydrogen
atoms fuses together produces a whole
bunch of energy and that's what produces
light from stars well when when the
stars were forming typically what was
happening was the stars were forming and
they were spinning around a bit and they
would have this kind of disk of stuff
that was spinning around with them and
what happens is just like the galaxies
form a clump things get clumpy ER and
compeer as a result of gap of gravity
the stars form things that compare and
clump eeeh
similarly in this kind of disk of stuff
around the region where the star is
forming that disk also mitt gets company
and Campea and eventually forms into
planets and and it's it's a it's kind of
a little fluffy
you know fluffy things that form at
first for planets and planets would
crash into each other and they were dumb
and other ones would come out and and
they would be you know two planets are
about the same size would be attracted
by gravity and they crash into each
other they form one planet and so on and
so on and so on and that that gradually
happened and as that happened eventually
things cool down and the things that are
small turn into planets if they were
much bigger they would turn into stars
like Jupiter is big planet but too small
to be a star but big on fairly big on
the size of planets um now what happened
for example the earth the earth is kind
of weird but so it's this this thing
about sort of discs of stuff accreting
and forming things it happens yet again
there are moons around planets same
phenomenon again so around stars there
are planets around planets there are
moons one of the things that you might
ask is are there are there moon moons
are there moon moons around moons and in
a sense if we put an artificial
satellite around our moon we would have
a moon around the moon actually it's a
tricky thing in mathematics of gravity
and things
actually it's actually pretty hard to
have moon moons because it turns out
that as them as the moon's orbit in
their orbits they will tend to put
forces on the moon moons that will make
the moon moons tend to tend to be pulled
out of their orbit so so actually moon
moons are rare you can have stars to
planets to moons but few moon moons and
I don't think there are any known in our
solar system yet um but in any case the
the thing that um that happens so in our
solar system like our moon is very big
compared to earth as a planet compared
to most moon most moons a planet's a
really small compared to their planets
and our moon there's been a big question
how did the moon form when I was a kid
people sometimes said oh the moon formed
out of a sort of scar on the earth left
by the Pacific Ocean that turns out not
to be true but um there are there are
sort of theories I think the current
favorite theory is this big splat theory
that says that there were two things of
roughly equal size and they collided and
they formed into and and in the early
Earth there was a sort of a big piece
that formed actually the moon the one
thing we know about the moon is the
earth is comparatively uniform the moon
is very lumpy the moon is like not
really if you looked inside the moon
it's got different stuff on one side
compared to the other and we know that
because when satellites orbit the moon
they don't they don't follow quite the
same sort of orbits that you would
expect if the moon was more or less
uniform they they have they kind of
wiggle and their orbits in a certain way
so so roughly the answer is you know the
earth formed by comes ok there's there's
another tricky thing so in the original
in the early universe
there were protons neutrons electrons
but there weren't any elements other
than hydrogen basically there was only
hydrogen gas which is the first element
the element that has a single proton and
in its in its simplest form a hydrogen
atom is just a single proton on a single
electron so questions how did the
heavier elements form and the answer is
they formed in stars and because in our
Sun our Sun is turning lots of hydrogen
into helium by fusing together hydrogen
nuclei hydrogen atoms to make helium and
then that keeps going and hydrogen turns
into helium stars burn helium so to
speak that's not burning in the same
senses in a fire it's some it's this
fusing of atoms by nuclear fusion and
helium turns into lithium and beryllium
and the heavier elements but actually it
turns out in an ordinary star you never
get beyond beyond iron it turns out the
way the elements work iron is which
number elements is that I don't know the
isotope of iron which is the counts of
the total number of protons and the
number of neutrons in the nucleus iron
56 is the is the sort of bottom of the
well it's the thing that is that if sort
of all else is equal it's the it's the
most it's the most tightly bound well no
it's the it's the it's the nucleus
that's sort of the most favored in terms
of energy for one to end up in so what
happens in stars is they slowly I mean
our Sun is mostly turning hydrogen into
helium but as stars get older they they
tend to turn more they make heavier and
heavier elements now of course in us you
know what are we made of or we're mostly
water which is you know hydrogen oxygen
and we're bunch of carbon you know if we
look at the earth the most common
elements in the Earth's crust a silicon
and aluminium aluminium um and so those
are somewhat heavier elements so how did
those get made
well our Sun isn't right now making
those elements not in substantial
numbers so how did those get made well
the answer is when stars get older some
stars it won't happen to our Sun but it
happens to stars bigger than our Sun as
the star has finished going through all
its hydrogen it will slowly it will
start to and that the star will
typically swell up and then as it as it
goes through it's sort of fuel
eventually it comes to this point where
the star will start to collapse and what
can happen is at a at a sort of critical
critical moment the star will collapse
very rapidly and as it collapses it will
push together nuclei are heavier and
heavier elements and eventually it will
push things together so much that things
like oxygen and silicon and heavier
elements like that
start to undergo nuclear fusion and that
produces a huge amount of energy and so
what happens to the star the star
explodes in a supernova and it releases
a huge amount of energy and supernovas
happen probably in our galaxy about once
every thousand years we last saw one our
civilization last saw one in 1054 ad
made the Crab Nebula and it's it was it
was kind of spectacular I think I mean I
think it was a little dot of light a
little little piece a little star that
made things bright at night so it was so
bright that um from that supernova
that's a long way away I think it's a
thousand light years with me not sure
I'm the that even at that distance the
supernova is releasing so much energy it
makes the the sky break just from this
one point of light their supernova is
happening in other galaxies that we can
see kind of all the time but in our
galaxy they not happen they probably
probably happen once every thousand
years at least that we can see them
maybe it's a little bit more frequent
than that if they're close to the plane
of the galaxy which tends to be hidden
by dust um but in any case the the so in
these supernovas so in a big star when
it when it undergoes this this rapid
contraction it it explodes and produces
all this energy and in that explosion
heavy elements are produced and so
something like Gold is produced in a
supernova explosion there's actually one
other process in okay fancy words
there's think'll our process and s
process nuclear synthesis which are two
different processes for making making
elements and stars but the one I'm
describing is the is the case in
supernovas which is which is a common
case um and so all the heavy elements
like gold or even like um like iron like
well like all of all of the elements
beyond the iron were basically made in
supernovas so when we like on the earth
if we look at you know when we go mining
on the earth we'll find all kinds of
elements like um if we pick up a thing
in the Earth's crust you know most of
the time a rock is made of silicates
silicon and aluminum and things about on
average if we look at atoms and the
earths
first on average one in every ten
billion atoms is a Gold atom and every
one of those gold atoms basically came
from a supernova that happened sometime
earlier in the history of our galaxy and
so if you ask where did the earth come
from well all of the all of the sort of
heavier elements in the earth were sort
of the result of earlier supernovas that
happened earlier stars kind of guide to
make what turned into things that are in
our Sun and in the earth and so on um
the sea
um
questions here about math teaching I'm
gonna I'm gonna turn answer more of the
science questions for kids medical
students using Mathematica learn
computational thinking learn to think
about things computationally is my main
I main point
okay question here how is it possible to
distinguish gravity from acceleration
and centrifugal force if you're in a
black box okay all right
so the here's the thing there's this
thing called the principle of
equivalence and the principle
equivalence says that if you are so it's
okay
people may know if you go up an elevator
and tall building right the elevator
starts accelerating as you go up the
building and you are pushed down to the
floor okay it's as if there's more
gravity from the earth the acceleration
of your of the elevator going up is the
equivalent of more gravity pulling you
down to the floor and so this principle
of equivalence says that there actually
is no difference between the forces that
come as a result of acceleration and the
forces that come as a result of gravity
at least if you're in a kind of isolated
black box and that principle that
there's no difference between the forces
of acceleration the forces of gravity is
one of the best verified principles in
science it's actually verified it's
known to be one part in ten to the
fifteen one part in a thousand trillion
so in into accuracy of one in a thousand
trillion we know that the acceleration
acceleration is the same as as as
gravity how do we know that actually
it's kind of a cool story when Apollo 11
went to the moon in 1969 one of the
things they took a bunch of instruments
and one of the instruments they took was
a laser retroreflector
so it's kind of like a road sign it's
got little little wrote road signs of
these little glass granules in them that
reflect light back the way it came the
lunar laser retroreflector has things
are like cat's eyes they like come the
cat's eyes on roads not cat's eyes in
cats these little spheres of glass and
and it's a they put that retro reflector
on the moon and people have been shining
lasers at that retro reflector ever
since and measuring exactly how long it
takes a
beam of laser light to hit the
retroreflector come back to the earth
again and that's allowed the distance to
the moon to be measured to a fraction of
a centimeter I think it's now down to
millimeters the so we know precisely
where the moon is and so we can use
theories about gravity and the
mathematics of that to work out whether
it's really true that acceleration and
gravity are that you can always sort of
trade-off acceleration for gravity so
that's that's how I'm in a in a sort of
black box if you are an isolated thing
you can tell you you can't tell whether
whether you're sort of locally in a you
know when you're in that elevator
accelerating up
it could be oops I'm actually living on
a planet with a larger larger gravity or
no I'm actually in an elevator now if
you if you allow yourself to see larger
distance it's a different story if you
allow yourself to look at what happens
at different places then you have to bet
then you can kind of then you can see oh
there's actually a gravitational field
that produces that pattern of
accelerations it's not something due to
purely due to it's not something do to
accelerate due to me being accelerated I
mean there's a lot more to say about
that I could talk about how that works
in black holes and things um okay well
there's a question here if you if the if
we think about the universe as a quantum
computer and we ask what the and we ask
how does the universe know to follow the
rules of that computer well gosh you
guys are asking about physics this is
great because I'm about to I mean I
figured out some really really
interesting things about how fundamental
physics works which I'm really excited
to talk about but I kind of want to get
um get it so it's well organized and I
can really explain it to people and also
frankly when nobody's paying attention
to anything other than the virus it's
kind of the wrong time to tell us the
world but I'm hoping in a few weeks I'll
be able to talk about this but so I'm
really I'm really excited that you guys
are asking about physics because I have
some really interesting things to
about it but tum the question really is
why does the universe follow the rules
that it follows why does it why
don't--why their definite rules for the
universe why is it the case that there
are laws for physics why doesn't why
don't different particles just do their
own thing as they feel like it well it's
one of the very fundamental facts we
know about the universe is that it has
laws and and like when people you know
early theologians were talking about
some kind of sort of arguments for for
religion and so on one of the one of the
things that they noticed it's a very
good observation is one of the
remarkable things about our universe is
that there's regularity in it it's not
obvious that that should exist why is
there regularity in our universe
actually I am happy to say that I
actually have an answer to that now and
the answer is quite interesting quite
abstract and not for this moment but so
I don't know I don't know why there is a
universe versus there isn't a universe
but I do know why there's a universe and
it has characteristics like our universe
um
okay question here is what is heat okay
boy let's
physics questions alright let me explain
what heat is um so you have any material
any ordinary material is made of atoms
molecules that are made of atoms um the
only things that aren't made of atoms
are things like light that are made of
photons which are a different kind of
particle but atoms which have protons
and neutrons and electrons and so on and
them those are you know ordinary things
are made of those and so anything we
have you know some thing of water or
something it's all a bunch of atoms and
it's a lot of atoms so in this sum in
this thing of water there will be let's
see can I do the math quickly enough
maybe a billion trillion trillion atoms
and this in this water bottle um so
there lot of atoms um but and those
atoms are all kind of bouncing around
and they're hitting each other they're
bouncing off they're hitting other atoms
and so on um
now sometimes atoms can be arranged very
regularly so when you have a crystal
like a diamond or a quartz crystal or
something like this there the atoms are
arranged in a very regular way
in fact in any solid the atoms are
arranged so that they're all kind of
standing still not quite but roughly all
the atoms are kind of standing still if
you in a liquid the atoms are running
around a bit more in a gas the atoms are
running around all over the place and
the fact that we can like if we if we
have a solid thing we push the solid
thing we can't go through it that's
because they're a bunch of atoms there
and they're not moving out of the way in
the case of a gas the atoms are running
around all over the place all the time
and so it's easy for us to sort of push
our way through the gas because the
atoms get out of the way because they're
they're moving around all the time okay
what makes atoms move around what makes
atoms move around as heat and that's
what heat heat is heat is the average
motion of atoms so when we say what's
the temperature of that thing what we're
doing is we're actually measuring the
average
the average actually even the average
speed of those molecules running around
and so when we when we are when we say
when we measure something with a
thermometer what's happening is that
that thermometer is effectively
measuring well it's basically the
average energy of molecules running
around inside our and pointing to my
mouth when I'm talking about
thermometers but but if it was a
thermometer for human temperature it
would be a measuring measuring the rate
at which molecules are bouncing around
inside my mouth and that causes the
molecules inside the the thermometer to
bounce around at kind of the same with
the same energy the same not quite the
same speed because they're different
molecules but but roughly the same speed
and that causes that that causes the and
that's what we then record as as as
temperature because what's happening in
a thermometer and a modern thermometer
what's happening is as those atoms are
moving around they're causing they're
kicking electrons out of where they
would otherwise be in a semiconductor
and their cause I think that's how
thermometers are working these days yeah
they're probably working using the
thermoelectric effect which is basically
heat heat is kind of kicking electrons
and causing them to make electric
currents but so what is heat heat is the
average motion of atoms so it's it's the
as you make things hotter the atoms are
moving around faster and when things are
really cold the the force of attraction
between atoms will just hold the atoms
in place and you make a solid as they
make the atoms hotter eventually the
force of attraction between atoms is not
sufficient to overcome the kind of the
the heat that's making the atoms run
around you get a liquid you heat it up
even further you get a gas because the
atoms are moving around really fast and
so one question you might ask is is
there is there a you know what happens
when the atoms go slower and slower and
slower and slower and so you might say
there must be a minimum temperature
because there must be a point at which
the atoms are just standing still
there's no more you can't take any more
energy out of the atoms they don't have
a
at all they're just standing still and
that's actually true
there's a thing called the absolute zero
of temperature - 273.16 degrees
centigrade is the absolute zero of
temperature and you can't make there is
no there's no meaning to temperature
below that because that's the
temperature at which there's no running
around energy on the part of the atoms
and so at that temperature basically
everything as a solid every every
material has its atoms have slowed down
to the point where they get grabbed by
other atoms and the thing makes the
solid in the in sort of full disclosure
there is one exception to that that's
known which is the helium for the
isotope of helium that's the common
isotope of helium is does not make a
solid at Absolute Zero it is a liquid at
Absolute Zero and that's a result of
quantum mechanics and it's a result of
what's called zero-point energy which is
something I'd be happy to talk about but
it's just a more complicated thing but
in a first approximation the atoms stop
at Absolute Zero and that's why
everything as a solid and heaters there
is the average motion of atoms um let's
see
uh question here I can
imagine virtual particles pushing
charges of let's not do that one I'll do
that one when I talk about how I think
physics actually works um okay
no question here if a I reached human
levels of functioning will be considered
a life-form good question you know it's
some I think the first question is will
be considered intelligent in the same
way that we think of ourselves as
intelligent the that's a complicated
issue because when when I was a kid I
keep on saying when I was a kid because
I figure people might find it
interesting to think about what changes
over these over this course of time but
um you know people would say when
computers can play chess when computers
can do mathematics when computers can
sort of autonomously move around then we
will call them intelligent when
computers can answer questions when
about sort of everyday life will will
call them intelligent well every single
one of those things we've managed to get
computers to do even some of them I've
been deeply involved personally in
getting computers to do those things
um the but yet people say oh but that's
not intelligence that's just software
engineering or that's just a computer
doing it well the fact is the it's you
know I don't think there is an abstract
definition of intelligence in fact one
of the things that's come out of science
that I've done is the sort of this idea
there really isn't an abstract
difference between the intelligent and
the merely computational so I don't
think there's a way to say oh on this
side that's intelligent on that side
it's just a computer and you might say
well gosh I mean we could you know
people do all these cool things and you
know when we have a computer we can just
look inside we can see all the bits
going around and we can see the computer
did this because this neural net had
this bit that worked in this way well ok
sad fact
we'll be able to measure what happens
inside our brains well enough to be able
to do the exact same thing and we'll be
able to say that brain you know I said
that word because this pattern of
electrical activity in my brain caused
this to happen that caused that to
happen that caused me eventually to say
that word and like for example in Birds
we kind of know pretty much how the song
you know how their brains make the kinds
of songs that birds produce do we then
conclude that they're completely
uninteresting because we know how they
work I don't think so I think it's the
same thing that we saw in those little
programs I was showing you that it
called cellular automata the little
black and white squares and so on even
though we know the rule it can still do
very non-trivial things and that's a
that's a feature of this phenomenon of
computational irreducibility
that even though you know the rule even
though you know the rule by which the
bird produces the song that doesn't mean
there's nothing to the song so to speak
even though we know that might know the
rules one day by which our brains do
everything they do that doesn't mean
there's nothing to what our brains do
and so I think that that term this
question of when do you have a sort of
an AI that is kind of like a human is is
is a little bit confused by that now
another issue is people say well look at
these AIS they're doing all these kinds
of things you know one day that will do
everything that humans do
okay there's sort of a definitional
problem with that because one of the
things that that a eyes don't know how
to do I sort of by definition is to know
what they want to do like humans how do
we know what we want to do how did I
decide to do this particular live stream
I thought it'd be kind of fun I thought
people might find it interesting you
know but that's a very arbitrary thing
that comes about because of my
particular history of you know the way
things are set up the fact that there's
this terrible pandemic and so on the
fact that all these other things there's
it's some it's something that my
particular human goals what I choose to
do as a human are something that come
out of a long kind of history of of
what's happened with us humans and so
you know this idea of so what do you
want to do
something that we can answer as humans
based on our whole sort of history and
civilization and so on but a raw AI that
says you've got a super smart AI okay
what does it want to do it doesn't know
what it wants to do it doesn't have a
whole civilization behind it unless we
put it in there and then you know we
have a slightly different situation then
we are defining the goals for the AI
then the AI is executing and I think
that's kind of the story of what's I
mean I you know in my efforts to make
computational language I see that as
being kind of a bridge to a eyes it's
like we humans can think in that
computational language which we can
communicate our goals to a eyes which
can then implement them I see this sort
of computational language as a bridge
between the human world of what we want
and the AI world of what can be executed
by a computer and so I think that's the
sort of the way to think about it I
might say that I you know I kind of
think this whole you know AI is the
first example of alien intelligence that
we have and it's often very weird
knowing you know we look inside an AI we
look inside one of the neural nets we
say how did that image identifier work
why did it decide that that was a rabbit
rather than an eel um you know we can
look inside it we can say well this
particular artificial neuron this
particular bit in the neuron that was
this why did that mean it decided it was
a rabbit not an eel and we have a very
complicated story explaining what what
was going on there and that's kind of a
probably is
similarly complicated - if we could
measure what was going on in human brain
why did the person come to this
conclusion rather than that oh gosh so
many questions here well look I I
shouldn't go on too long here but I'm
happy to go a little bit longer here um
there's a question here do magnets work
in space yes absolutely they work in
space magnets have a magnetic field is
something that is it is a magnetic field
doesn't require a medium like air or
something to be transmitted so magnetic
field the and again this is terrible
because I I now think I actually
understand how this works an actual
in our actual universe and it's it's
kind of a complicated story but suffice
it to say that the that the way that
something like magnetic field gets
transmitted doesn't require us to have a
medium of any kind that we kind of know
about now you can you can you can block
a magnet you can you can make you can
just like you can you can put it
something in which as a shield that will
prevent a magnetic field getting through
and you can do that for electrical
signals too you can if you put if you if
you're inside a copper box a box that's
a good conductor you won't be able to
get electromagnetic signals out of that
box um it's interesting that you can
block electromagnetic waves you cannot
block gravity there is no way to block
gravity gravity is always you can block
electrical effects but you can't block
gravitational effects at least that's
the way I think let's see
good question in my theory of physics
can you make a gravity shield I think
the answer is no but I would have to
think about that more carefully to know
for sure but I think the answer is sorry
the gravity shield model of science
fiction is just not going to cut it
we're not going to be able to shield
gravity as we can shield electrical
electrical forces and so on
let's see
so question here is a dead virus the
virus with part of its protein removed
it's it's a virus with its replication
mechanism removed um I actually don't
know the precise definition of the dead
virus for purposes of vaccines but but
the main thing the main main point about
it is it does not have what it takes to
be able to infect and replicate in cells
what book behind me had the most impact
on me and my peers there's a good
question actually I have it's terrible
because I I so rarely do this in an
actual setting like this I well okay I
have to reach down on the floor here
it's a bad sign that it's on the floor
you know this is my favorite of course
this is a big book that I spent a long
time writing but um if I look at my um
my collection of books I actually do
have some sort of classic books up there
um I have a Newton's book on prank
appear that was the book that kind of
introduced well introduced the idea of
gravity actually the idea the
inverse-square law of gravity and also
much of calculus I have what else do I
have there oh I have I have an Origin of
Species up there from Darwin I also have
I also have some other books some up
there like I have a book by Darwin about
barnacles which are these types of
creatures that get stuck on boats Darwin
spent many many years studying barnacles
and studying the details of how they
worked and actually his book on
barnacles
he spent longer on than he spent on
Origin of Species I let's see what else
do I have up there I have a whole
collection of classic books there oh
I've got Bulls book on them which was
the introduction of boolean algebra I've
got um the little tiny book that Galileo
published in 1608 that was the
announcing the discovery of the moons of
Jupiter the first time people had seen
something orbiting something other than
than the Sun um and I would say a few of
those books are sort of first edition
type things mostly those are just
reprints that I find interesting to look
at from time to time I'm probably some
others another time maybe I'll talk
about some of those I'm somebody asking
about history of computing I do know a
certain amount about about history of
computing as personal and asking about
the interpretation of quantum mechanics
I'm happy to say we have a new really
new interpretation of quantum mechanics
that really makes sense and I think we
nailed it I think we actually know how
it works and I've been wondering how it
works for 50 years so I'm really excited
about that um okay how can I electron
have a different energy if it moves the
speed of light and has constant mass so
electrons don't move at the speed of
light the only things that move at the
speed of light are particles that don't
have a rest mass and the only particles
we know for sure that don't have a rest
mass are photons particles of light and
gravitons which are the particles that
are associated with gravity which we
haven't don't know as much about as we
know about photons of particles of light
but we know that gravitational waves and
light waves both go at speed of light
and the particles associated with those
are photons and gravitons and they both
go at the speed of light and we have
pretty good evidence that gravitational
waves go at the speed of light same
speed as light goes at electrons a
massive particles they don't go at the
speed of light in fact um it's really
really hard to get an electron to go
really close to the speed of light and
in big particle accelerators people are
trying to get electrons to go really
close to the speed of light and they get
them to go 99.999 see I can't work it
out in my head how many nines it is but
99.999 something-or-other percent of the
speed of light they don't quite get them
to go at the speed of light how can that
be what what happens well what happens
is it takes more and more energy to make
something go closer and closer the speed
of light you can't get any particle with
mass to go exactly at the speed of light
only massless particles can go exactly
at the speed of light and it's a
consequence of relativity theory um that
you get this mass increase as you try
and it's an effective increase of mass
as you get close to the speed of light
and that's why as you try and get
something to go Casta feel like that's
harder and harder and harder and in this
new physics there in mind there is a
beautiful explanation of how that all
works this is terrible I'm I'm um you
guys are really encouraging me to to
really get that term that theory
announced
I'm and I and I will soon um I'm thank
you for encouraging me that's very it's
very very nice um I just might mention
um the you know there are some other
particles that people thought had zero
mass neutrinos there's strange particles
that people discovered in the well kind
of invented in 1950s and they were first
observed in the 1960s their particles
that interact so weakly that they're
produced in the Sun as a result of
nuclear reactions and but the most
neutrinos that go from the Sun to the
earth go all the way through the earth
they just they go through the earth and
they don't stop neutrinos as the energy
of a neutrino goes up the rate at which
it interacts goes up and that's how a
neutrinos were actually observed is by
making higher energy neutrinos that
actually don't just go through the whole
earth without stopping um but you tree
knows it turns out have a tiny mass that
so they're not actually massless
particles they go very close to speed of
light but probably not actually it's
being light um okay people are asking
about why stars go from white to red I I
think in the main sequence which is the
sequence on which stars of a certain
range of masses evolve there are changes
of temperature that will lead to them
going to different term
a different term yes I think that's what
happens I okay something I remember
learning oh be AF g/km right that's the
sequence of the main city that's the
main sequence of stars that's the
spectral types of stars and that's and
our son is a g-type star um and yes that
they go through a sequence I think
changing their temperature and that's
why they change their color sort of an
exercise if you want to understand these
things is why are there no green stars
and the answer is because by the time
you have if you're in that part of the
spectrum you're you're you're producing
when you when you produce light from
heat you're producing um you have a
spectrum which covers all the colors
you never are concentrated in the green
that's why it will look white not green
um what happens if we filter all the
electrons from an element okay so
normally in an ordinary atom you have
the atomic nucleus which has protons
which have positive charge you have
electrons which are of negative charge
they sort of going outside the nucleus
and it cancels out and your your average
atom has zero charge but um you can in
chemistry for example atoms often have
their electrons kind of taken away and
shared with other atoms and that is what
ionic bonding is for example sodium
chloride salt comes from but also as you
heat an atom up eventually the electron
will no longer be be held into the atom
and the electron will be will be pulled
out of the atom we ripped out of the
atom and that's what produces what's
called the plasma and for example in
fire fire as a plasma and fire when when
fire is glowing and things it is a
plasma that in which the the the atoms
no longer have their full complement of
electrons and so like the surface of the
Sun is a plasma there so when you rip
electrons out of atoms they form plasmas
and that's and they're very implies m'as
for example absorb light in certain ways
emit light in certain ways now you might
ask the question what happens if you
could rip all of the all of the
electrons out from from an atom what
would it be like well it would be this
very high charge thing and so it would
really really try and pull in electric
charges and it would quickly neutralize
itself there's one exception in our
universe which is neutron stars so one
of the things that can happen to a star
a little bit more massive than our Sun
is that as a result so for example when
there's a supernova explosion a big
explosion lots of stuff gets thrown out
with very high energy but something is
left over and what can be left over at a
certain range of masses of stars again
is probably some astronomer watching
this who knows exactly I think it's one
point
two solar masses maybe 1.2 times mass of
Sun I've forgotten the that what's left
over is a neutron star what is a neutron
star a neutron star is like a giant
atomic nucleus it's something where the
what's happened is that it's usually
about 10 kilometers across and it is
about the mass of our Sun but it's this
very very dense thing so the mass of our
Sun our Sun is what half a million
kilometers across or something and that
the whole of our Sun just crushed into
this thing ten kilometers across makes a
neutron star neutron star has 100
trillion times the density of water and
what is it it's just a whole bunch of
neutrons altogether so in in a standard
atomic nucleus there are both protons
and neutrons protons have electric
charge like charges repel so if you just
put too many protons in there they will
be they'll tend to just push each other
apart okay so one of the things you
might ask you might be you might ask the
question if protons are positively
charged and like charges repel how is it
that atomic nuclei hang together and
that's because of a thing called the
strong nuclear force and what happens is
there is a different kind of kind of
force that is associated with this thing
called QCD quantum chromodynamics the
theory of quarks and gluons that force
binds together protons the thing that
immediately happens is there are things
called pi ons which nobody ever hears
about you know it's one of the tragedies
of high school physics is they don't
teach particle physics the particle
physics is not that complicated at least
the sort of it's it's zoology of what
kinds of particles exist and not that
complicated but they never teach it
people they took talk about protons and
neutrons and electrons but inside nuclei
there's another kind of particle that
exists at least in temporarily called pi
ons and pi ons are these particles about
one-tenth the mass of an electron of a
proton that are continually being
bounced backwards and forwards between
the protons and nucleus and they're what
lead to the force of attraction between
the protons and a nucleus and what
prevent the nucleus from from
self-destructing but anyway that in a
neutron star things have been crushed to
the point where there is the protons are
all gone all it is is neutrons and
there's just a whole lot of neutrons and
that is like a giant piece of atomic
nucleus so that a neutron star is just
like a single atomic giant atomic
nucleus and that's what you get now a
neutron star has some it's very massive
and neutron stars can spin around and
the whole star so the Sun rotates slowly
um and but how fast does the Sun rotate
I should know the answer to that because
you can tell from sunspot rotation and
things but it's on the order of months
maybe I've forgotten but the how fast it
turns on its axis and you know the earth
turns on its axis once a day but a
neutron star a whole neutron star can
turn on its axis once every second or
maybe even a thousand times a second and
one of the weird things that happens is
neutron stars as a result of producing
big gravitational field they can
actually they can they can accelerate
particles and we can actually they
produce radio signals and we can
actually detect those radio signals so
back in 1968 people started hearing
these detecting these radio signals that
were making this kind of noise they were
making a rapid oscillation and so they
didn't know what these were and that the
for the first couple of weeks they
thought maybe it was an extraterrestrial
civilization that was had a beacon that
was just producing you know was a
periodic beacon that we were detecting
but then it was realized actually it was
neutron stars and they're pulsars which
are spinning neutron stars spinning
every second or sometimes more rapidly
than that and so on and that's what so
that's what what a typical are giant
atomic nucleus is like that giant atomic
nuclei are very very weird they have
well okay to make a slightly more
advanced comment they they have a
phenomenon called super fluidity they
they they act like a liquid that has no
verse no viscosity
runs perfectly they have all kinds of
other weird features um and that's
that's something that can happen okay
I
electrons coming from that spring into
existence from from where well okay look
one of the big surprises in the world is
that every electron is the same okay why
is that true you know it's like you
might have thought well they're about
ten to the eighth electrons in our
universe see I know the guy can
translate that number easily one with
with 8000 in the universe and every one
of those electrons is the same every one
of those electrons has the same rest
mass has the same spin the same rate at
which it's spinning around and so on it
has the same properties when it
interacts with matter
every one is the same and that is a very
interesting problem in physics why
they're all the same so friend of mine
physicist reserves dead now but but had
for a while had the weird theory maybe
the reason all electrons are the same is
because they're all the same electron
and that what's happening is that
electron is going forwards in time
zipping backwards in time going back
forwards in time and so on and that's
why every electron is the same electron
very electron has the same properties
because it's the same electron I don't
think that's correct I think that that
we kind of know that particular theory
isn't correct but in the things I
figured out in physics I think we know
why why all the electrons are the same
and it's more like it's more a sort of
fact about the same computation always
does the same thing um the question here
why is the human brain so mushy you mean
physically or I'm happy to say I've
never physically seen one I'm I would be
totally squeamish although I that is is
what I hear that that there I think um
you know there like like the rest of us
they've got lots of fluid in them is it
necessary for the operation of the brain
I think that it is important to take
those neurons those neurons have to be
powered somehow and having you know the
way we have to you know they have to get
them you know they have to have blood
supply they have to have other
coming to them in the end the neurons
are going to act electrically the
neurons are like little they have the
equivalent little tiny batteries that
are what causes them to produce the the
little pulses of electricity that are
presumably what make up the way that
brains work I mean it's still not
completely clear how brains work but
although it's becoming a little clearer
because we have artificial analogues of
them in the neural nets that are part of
certain modern artificial intelligence
um and it's some and we know that
there's a network of you know in human
brains maybe a hundred trillion no
they're about maybe a trillion or so
neurons with maybe a hundred or thousand
times that many connections the neurons
are these very tree like looking things
and they have these connections between
them and probably our memories are
associated with little tiny pieces of
things like calcium that are in the in
the actual synapses the connections
between neurons probably the pattern of
of strengths of those connections is
what stores our memories and that's also
what stores the memories and the
artificial neural Nets that we make in
an AI and so on and that's and they're
there and I mean that's the that's the
most common theory for how brains work
is that that's how memory is stored
there are other theories that are still
conceivable but I think are much less
likely do you think it's possible to
communicate with other worlds outside
our solar system so one of the big
questions is are we actually going to be
able to make a spacecraft that goes to
Alpha Centauri the nearest star for
light-years away
um the nearest star other than the Sun
well it's it's really it's tough to make
a spacecraft that can go that far it's
gonna take a really long time one of the
things that's sort of surprising is that
if you just keep accelerating you just
keep accelerating you get to go really
quite fast if you can succeed in keeping
on accelerating even if the acceleration
is really very little acceleration if
you do it for long enough eventually you
build up to go quite fast as I explained
before when you go close to the speed of
light
it gets harder and harder and harder to
push the object to go even even faster
close to the speed of light there are
also other problems like if you're going
close to the speed of light your tooling
along your spacecraft you're going
through interstellar space between our
Sun and the nearest star um it's like
are you gonna hit things well it turns
out there's about one hydrogen atom per
cubic centimeter in interstellar space
so and but if you're going really close
to the speed of light even that can be a
problem and if there was a speck of dust
there
you're toast your spacecraft is going to
be completely destroyed going at the
speed of light
you hit a speck of dust it's kind of
from tremendous amount of energy is
exchanged and it's kind of bad news
but um in the so there's a question of
can you can you accelerate something to
go and get it to go close enough the
speed of light you can get to Alpha
Centauri and a reasonable time getting a
big spacecraft there is going to be
really tough there's people I know who
have an idea that they're going to get
really tiny spacecraft they're actually
I was I I got a little thing maybe I
could get up and get today okay I'm
gonna just one little prop here let's
see if I can find it no I don't forget
it I have a little little thing I was at
a an event and I was a person showing
off from showing off a very very tiny
little device that might be a thing that
could be used as a very very very tiny
spacecraft and so it's a little tiny
circuit and it has these little tiny
wires that hang out from it and the idea
is instead of sending a big spacecraft
to let's say the nearest star send a
really really tiny spacecraft and maybe
push it by using a powerful laser on the
earth light when you have a beam of
light that hits something and is
reflected back let's say you have a
mirror the photon hits the mirror and
the photon is reflected back it's a
little bit like a billiard ball you know
or ball you you hit something and the
ball is reflected back
the momentum of the ball a little bit of
the momentum of the ball is transferred
to the object that reflects the the ball
back and the same thing happens for
photons and so if you have a powerful
laser and you can have a thing that is
reflecting the laser light there will be
a small force exerted by that laser
light so if you if you shine this laser
and you can shine it on something and
you keep shining it for a long time it
will gradually accelerate the thing and
if your spacecraft is tiny enough you
can make it go pretty fast and maybe you
can make it eventually go to to the
nearest star well I was at this event
and the person was showing this off and
I was like come can i buy one of these
things from you because I just want to
be able to say that I bought a starship
for five bucks or something so I have a
little tiny circuit board which is a
prototype let's say starship that is of
the type that might one day be sent to a
turret to other stars now one thing I
might mention it's a consequence of
relativity is that if you if we sent
people for example to other stars V and
we accelerated them so that they were
going very close to the speed of light
and let's say it took in our
measurements it took two thousand years
for people to really long time for
people to go they accelerating the
spacecraft they they finally get to
Alpha Centauri they decelerate they
slowed down they come back again and
they come back to earth and for us two
thousand years has passed for them
they're like oh oh you know that was a
while it was like twenty years but it
wasn't 2,000 years and so there's this
weird thing it's called the twin paradox
that's a consequence of relativity
theory that says that when you have an
object that is going really fast
time will effectively elapse slower for
the object that's going really fast than
for one that isn't and actually we now
understand why this happens and roughly
what's happening is if you think of if
you think of sort of the universe trying
to work out what it's going to do you
can it happens at a certain rate time is
elapsing at a certain rate and there's
sort of a trade-off between you sampling
more of the universe by moving in space
at a certain speed and the universe
updating itself and I soon when I can
explain this whole physics theory I can
make that a lot more precise but in in
standard relativity theory there is a
it's a feature of relativity theory it's
a it's essentially a consequence of if
you assume that there's nothing can go
faster than the speed of light the only
way to make a consistent physics is to
assume that space and time are distorted
if you are going at a speed that's close
to the speed of light that's the only
way to say nothing is going to explain
two things ok so if you are running
along and let's say you have you hear a
siren go by and well the siren you hear
the math is not the best way to explain
it um if you you're producing a sound
well this sound travels at a certain
speed it travels at the speed of sound
in air the speed of sound is that the
sound is made of waves of compression
and rarefaction in air those those waves
travel at a certain speed it's about
some 300 m/s 700
it's it's sort of the thing that limits
the speed of standard airplanes as by
not they don't want to have air that
goes faster than the speed of sound over
their wings because the characteristics
of air are very different at the the
speed of sound than they are in below
the speed of sound but in any case so so
if we have something that's producing a
sound the it you have a thing producing
a sound the sound is going at 700 miles
an hour the it's some but the thing
that's producing the sound is the the it
can't that because there's air that's
stationary the sound can't go you don't
you don't get the sound is always just
going at the speed of sound the speed
that sound goes at in the stationary air
just because your your airplane is going
at 600 miles an hour doesn't mean that
the sound that comes out from it
is sort of going at 600 miles an hour
plus the speed of sound
um it's some I'm not explaining this
very well sorry the but basically that
the point is that there is a there is a
a medium that the sound is going in and
the sound goes at a certain speed in
that medium for light we don't think
there's any such medium but there is the
feature that even if the thing is going
at the speed of light even if you have a
flashlight going at the speed of light
the light that it emits can't go at
twice the speed of light for example the
flashlights going very close to the
speed of light it emits light at the
speed of light the light that comes out
doesn't go at twice the speed of light
it only goes at the speed of light and
to make that consistent the only way you
can make that consistent is to have to
imagine that length and time change when
you're going at a higher speed and
that's what leads to this trend paradox
thing that really happens as you go at a
higher speed time effectively slows down
and that the main place we don't see
that very often in in sort of real life
the only place we really see that is
with the GPS satellites the GPS
satellites that allow us to measure
position the way they measure position
is you get a fix on let's say three or
five GPS satellites and you know the
precise time that the radio signal came
from satellite number eleven or
something and reached you and from
knowing that precise time you can know
how far it was to satellite number
eleven and then by knowing the orbits of
those satellites you can compute based
on the distance to three satellites or
five satellites or whatever you can work
out exactly where you are but to know
that you have to know the precise time
at which the signal was emitted from the
GPS satellite and to know that depends
on because the GPS satellites are going
at orbital speed 17,000 miles an hour or
whatever their relativistic time
dilation as it's called will slow their
clocks down a bit now this would be a
great story this would be a great story
of this is an example of relativity in
action this is an example of the twin
paradox the GPS satellites are being
slowed down in the same way that the the
rapid explorers who go to Alpha Centauri
will be slowed down it would be a great
story but for the fact that GPS
satellites have computers in them and in
order to make it easier for GPS
receivers to process the data the GPS
satellites artificially changed their
clock speed to compensate for relativity
so they actually they actually don't and
that's a complicated thing to understand
that um but if left to natural if it was
a pendulum clock if it was some
mechanical device that was in there not
a clock that is connected to a computer
and sort of a smart clock it would
follow relativity and it would show time
dilation and so on um okay let's see um
well ah gosh they're questions here
about quantum computers you know the
story of quantum computers might change
a little bit
when this physics theory gets understood
um the let's see what's my take
specialization versus generalization and
learning about things you know I've been
lucky that I've learnt about a lot of
different things in my life and it's
some it's really cool the way that
knowing about one thing you can apply it
to other things but you have to be able
to do two things first you have to
remember what you learnt about the first
thing and second you have to have this
idea that yes you can apply things to
other things you know I've I've
interacted with like kids and so on my
own kids actually my own kids are bad
examples of this because they don't have
this particular issue but but um you
know they learn math for example and
then some math questions some something
that can be answered with math in
everyday life comes up and they just
can't do it and it's an amazing thing to
me it's a good exercise you know if
there's a thing that can be answered
with math you know that actually needs
Pythagoras's theorem or something like
that see if you can actually do it you
know you learnt that in school see if
you can actually apply it and and it's
it's a pity that people don't you know
they they learn how to do exercises like
with math or science for that matter but
it's like the you know it's sometimes
it's a it's it it's a strange thing to
actually apply these things you know
might my wife who has a math PhD is
sometimes it's very traumatized by the
fact you know i have okay i've happened
that with physics PhD from long ago but
i'll figure out like one can do this or
that very everyday thing you know this
particular wire can be connected in this
way and it's like you know surely you
need some expert to figure this out no
you know this is just physics i know how
to figure this out you know it's it's
it's going to work just fine and I think
even it even in that case there's a bit
of surprise you can actually like apply
these things that um that are sort of
things you learnt in math or some other
area you can apply them to other things
so if you are good at applying things to
other things then the more stuff you
know the better off you're gonna be
because then you know what I've
discovered in the stuff I've done I mean
I've been very lucky in the sense that
I've I've had the opportunity to make
use of
just tons of different kinds of
knowledge so for example in in you know
in Wolfram Alpha which is this thing
that provides computational knowledge
for Syrian Alexa and things like that um
the you know when we built wolf malphur
one of the things is its goal is to know
about everything and that's it that's a
cool project for somebody like me
because I like to know about everything
and it's it's like we have to be able to
program it to be able to answer
questions about all sorts of different
kinds of things and the more things you
know about the easier it is to figure
out new things so for example there's
things I've been doing about fundamental
physics um that story is a combination
of a bunch of fairly sophisticated ideas
about computing and computer science and
things about automated still improving
and things that had come from a bunch of
different areas that you kind of have to
pull together to make progress there um
so let's see
gosh is a question here how would you
think humanity would adapt to living
three or four times longer then because
I will to do things is driven by limits
of time it's a really interesting
question I've wondered quite a bit about
that I mean I think one of the things
that you know sort of our stage of human
history is right on the edge of is human
and mortality and you know we don't know
how to do it yet we still think you know
aging is inevitable we don't know how to
freeze thing you know how to sort of
pause things with cryonics and so on but
I'm quite certain that it is not the
case that sort of aging is inevitable
and sort of immortality is impossible
type thing I'm quite certain that that's
one of the things that we will look at
back at this period of science and maybe
we'll say gosh if we pushed harder on
that we would have figured it out I'm
not sure I think that relates to these
questions about how difficult is it to
work out what happens in biology and how
much is computational irreducibility a
thing here's one of the Downers to
thinking about immortality one of the
issues is let's say you turn around a
program you try to run a computer you
have your computer your computer is
running it's running its programs it's
running its operating system it keeps
running does just fine
after two weeks the computer crashes the
operating system crashes you have to
reboot it that's kind of like the next
generation like your computer running is
like an organism that's alive and it's
doing its thing and so on and so on and
so on and when the computer crashes the
operating system dies so to speak that's
like oops that organism died and you got
to restart it from nud from the same
genetic material and then it'll live
again for two weeks or something and so
one of the questions you can ask you
know in medicine we have you know these
classifications of human diseases we
know the outside or now like this and in
the US it's called icd-9 as the standard
classification of diseases and I think
it has about 40,000 diseases that are
listed of 40,000 things that can go
wrong with us um and if and and so those
are and the question is of four
computers could we do the same thing we
have a classification of what goes wrong
with computers you know when your
computer is running slowly oh it's
really old and tired it's his operating
system is about to crash and die and so
on his program is about to do that
what's actually happening well what's
happening is all kinds of weird stuff
you know all kinds of crud is building
up in its memory all kinds of detailed
things are happening inside the computer
nobody has ever really figured out what
the kind of the analog of medicine for
computers is like in other words when
people run in the cloud when they run
servers and things you know they run for
a while and then you have to reboot the
server you know things you there isn't
really an analogue of sort of disease
classification for computers I tried to
figure out something about how that
would work and the thing you realize is
it's actually really hard because of
this computational irreducibility thing
because it's hard to know when you make
this change to the computer this change
to the program what consequences will
have it's really hard to be able to
figure out that sort of how do we make
an intervention how do we how do we fix
things so that things will keep running
okay um and so that's that's one of the
things that makes it look really
difficult to like could we keep our
computer running forever could we have a
computer that just keeps running its
operating system never crashes that's
kind of like the the immortality problem
for biological organisms maybe or maybe
there are other mechanisms that exist in
the sort of molecular computing scale of
biological organisms that make it easier
I don't know but then the question is in
a world where we're kind of lifespans
are much longer how does that work with
respect to people sort of motivation to
do things and so on and I don't know the
answer to that it's a I mean I think the
sort of the thought experiment is
imagine that you know everybody was kind
of uploaded to this sort of giant cloud
of all humanity so to speak I think I've
sometimes referred to that as the box of
a trillion Souls model where it's kind
of every every the the essence of the
thought processes of everybody are kind
of kind of exist in this sum in this
sort of computational form and then the
question is okay so you have sort of
infinite time at least in your
computational time you have infinite
experience time to do things what do you
choose to do it's a really interesting
question
I don't know the answer I mean I think
the the bad news version of that would
be sort of all of the all of the future
of our you know the future sort of
disembodied humans are kind of playing
video games for the rest of eternity so
to speak
that's what to us now looks like a
pretty bad case scenario for the future
of history I personally don't think it
will be like that one of the reasons is
that if you asked you know you ask
people today why do you do what you do
you have a whole big explanation based
on current sort of current theories of
life like one of my favorite examples is
you know why do I walk on a treadmill
for you know a couple of hours every day
or whatever um you know well I do that
because I want to be healthier and
because I want to live longer because I
want to do this and so on but it's a
long chain of explanation and if you
were to tell somebody a thousand years
ago oh I'm gonna spend two hours a day
walking on a treadmill they just look at
you and they say that's absolutely nuts
why would you you know walk in one place
for two hours you you have to be insane
but because of the things that we now
know and the kind of the the structure
of sort of our goals today it makes
sense and I think at every time in human
history it has been the case the things
we do kind of make sense at that time in
history even though at a different time
in history
it might not make sense and things that
people did you know a thousand years ago
looking back they might not make sense
to us today but it's sort of okay
because the things that we're doing now
at least makes sense to us all right we
should probably wrap up soon but you
guys are asking such terrific questions
um
oh boy how we can
let's see um oh okay I'm going to
I'm gonna do I'm gonna just pick and
choose a few that I think of fun is it
theoretically possible to make a suit
that will make you grow and shrink that
will like an ant-man okay
interesting question given that I claim
I now understand something about how
fundamental physics works I should be
able to answer that question
the answer is well I don't think so
although in some bizarre sense there
might be so many copies of the universe
that you can be running in the universe
but that's a slightly more abstract
thing there is one effect that I that I
might mention that's kind of a weird
effect so atoms usually they're protons
neutrons electrons electrons are these
particles which people have always
thought are like point particles they
don't have an extent I think they
actually do have a small extent um but
but anyway there are things called muons
which are just like electrons but
they're about 206 times heavier than
electrons and there's even another thing
called a Tau leptin which is just like
muons and electrons but even heavier
still nobody's ever understood what
muons are why they why they exist but
muons are and you probably unfortunately
nobody's heard of me once new ones are
one of my favorite kinds of things in
the universe they're because they're so
bizarre mysterious and and so sort of
obvious in a sense but just like
electrons but about 206 times heavier
now it turns out cosmic rays from the
Sun they're they're high-energy
particles that come out of the Sun in
addition to producing light the Sun also
produces a bunch of other stuff solar
wind and which are charged particles
coming out from the Sun some of those
make cosmic rays which are just they're
mostly protons that hit the upper
atmosphere of the earth and the most of
the protons get it get get it absorbed
by the upper atmosphere and they produce
a cascade of particles and what we see
at sea level on the earth is a bunch of
muons
about I think it's about one a minute go
through a typical go through us so to
speak one of these little muons just
like an electron higher higher mass
they're quite quite energetic new ones
that go go through us
um and muons unlike electrons are
completely stable so far as we know
muons decay the the average muon decays
in two microseconds two millionths of a
second the but as a result of time
dilation relativistic time dilation that
I conveniently just mentioned the muons
that come in cosmic rays are going quite
fast and so they actually live a lot
longer than 2.2 microseconds and in
principle when a muon is going fast
enough you can have it live as long as
you want I mean if you have a muon
that's going at 99.99999% of the speed
of light you could have a muon that
would live for a few hours um and people
have even tried to imagine particle
accelerators in which muons would keep
going around for hours and hours it
hasn't actually been built but things a
little bit like that had been built um
but anyway so why am I telling you this
well because muons are just like
electrons except they're 206 times
heavier well if you were to conveniently
get an atom where all of its electrons
have been replaced by muons you would
have an atom that's 206 times smaller as
it turns out I think that's right maybe
I have to work out my Bohr radius for an
atom I think that's right yeah it's
linearly proportional to mass um the so
206 times smaller atoms than are
ordinary atoms so muonic atoms would be
said like ant-man sized atoms they have
only one bug not wishing to make the pun
with ants they're one bug is that the
muons and them decay in 2.2 microseconds
um so these muonic atoms they would be
small but they will decay very rapidly
and sorry it's not gonna work but so the
answer is I don't know anyway to do that
um
let's see
well there's a question here do you
think we'll get some kind
location theory in physics in our
lifetime I'm super much hoping that in a
few weeks we will have really really
interesting things to say about that I
mean the the the sort of the the coolest
thing is it turns out that essentially
relativity in quantum mechanics which
are the two big theories of 20th century
physics basically turn out to be the
same theory which is anyway I'm super
much looking forward to talking about
this I just want to get sort of
organized and you guys are very much
encouraging me to to do that okay so as
a question hit has a satellite stay in
orbit around the Earth it's because of
the force of gravity and what's
happening is when if you if you shoot a
rocket straight up on the earth and
nothing else happened it would just come
straight down again but if you if you
shoot it up and you insert it in orbit
you are you're making it kind of you're
making it go somewhat sideways it will
be like it tries to fall towards the
earth and as it falls towards the Earth
by the time it has sort of fallen it has
gone around the earth and that causes it
to go in an orbit and orbits
if around ordinary gravitating
gravitational objects are always
ellipses roughly circles um so that's
the that's the best I can say of that
and and the what the force that causes
it to stay in that orbit that attracts
it to the earth is the force of gravity
if two
scientists disagree should I believe the
bigger one what can I do if I have no
way to verify their statements how can I
decide who to trust is there a game I
can play to decide who is right that is
a very interesting question actually um
unfortunately I don't think you can
always trust the bigger group of
scientists in fact the bigger group of
scientists often has the greater ability
to delude themselves and get the wrong
answer
I mean it's happened a bunch of times in
the history of science I think it's some
you know one of the things that's really
complicated with science is you know
okay so back 400 years ago most in
science everybody thought science could
be figured out by common sense you know
in other words anything that was true
about science anybody could just sit and
figure out if the world worked this way
you could just by pure reason by pure
argumentation you could say yes that's
the way the world works I can figure it
out by common sense there was nothing
you had to trust just say okay
scientists have measured this and they
found this
therefore we trust that's how it works
that kind of changed with the kind of
Copernican revolution with the discovery
that well the stuff that we thought
based on you know aristotle and ptolemy
and so on about you know the sun going
around the earth that wasn't true
when was the actual story of the sisters
drawings but more complicated than this
but but in a first approximation that
was the first time there was really
evidence that the scientists had told us
something that wasn't obvious and you
know in the last 300 years or so that
has accelerated greatly there's more and
more stuff that you just have to trust
the scientists because for everyday
person can't verify it um you know I
must say that for me you know I know a
decent amount about science and I have
you know I have actually some ability to
you know go compute things and so on and
so I do have a habit of saying can I
verify things like you know four things
about this virus I'm like can I actually
compute that can I see how that works um
and so you know for me I'm sort of in
the in the position where I can
sometimes go figure it out
now you know in the abstract
can I figure out whether it makes sense
or not the best way I can do that is
really to know how does it fit in with
other things I already know and you kind
of have to know a bunch of science to
know whether it fits together and I
don't think in the abstract you know
given two groups of scientists who
violently disagree how do you tell you
know which one is right and which one is
wrong and can you kind of look them in
the eye and decide well that's kind of a
human question and I think you know
sometimes honestly you can and sometimes
even the intensity I mean one of the
things that's a strange feature of the
history of science the intensity with
which people object to a new idea is
often well correlated with its ultimate
success that is if a new idea comes out
and everybody's up in arms that can't
possibly be right
then that's often in the case where a
new idea comes out and people like I
don't care doesn't matter doesn't you
know who cares you know then who knows
whether that's right but in a case where
a new idea comes out and a lot of people
really jump on it said that can't
possibly be right most of the time
there's some exceptions to this where
where they're different kinds of forces
at work but a lot of the time that's for
me a good indicator that it's going to
be a winner of an idea at some time in
the future because people are used to a
particular way of thinking and something
new comes in but it's a really good
question I don't I don't know whether
there's a a good general way to do that
I mean I think one of the things that
that sort of a pity in science is when -
and when an area of science is young
there are a small number of people doing
it and the people who do it kind of know
that they are inventing things from
scratch and so if there's a major change
they're like oh well we invented that
from scratch so we might have it wrong
there could be a big change if you go
fifty or hundred years later the people
who are doing that science are the
seventh generation or something of
people and for them whatever was true at
the beginning whatever was thought at
the beginning is just absolutely true
now it's the wisdom of the Ancients so
to speak and you couldn't possibly
disagree with it and so for them if you
come along and say oh whoops physics
doesn't work that way for example
they're like no no we can't be true
we've known that it works that way for a
hundred years how can you possibly say
that
but so when a science is young there's
much more kind of ability to to adopt
new things than there is when the
science gets older and the other thing
that tends to happen is when a science
has been successful a lot of people
start doing it and so they end up being
these kind of structures built up of you
know the professional Society for this
kind of science and the official way
that this kind of science works and once
you have those things in place it's
pretty hard to you know to turn the ship
so to speak and that's it that's a
dynamic that III might argue as a little
bit happened in physics um and we shall
see um okay should science be available
to the public to be science is anything
hidden um let's see do you think science
can be a closed system that's an
interesting question
is there something that can can be
considered science if it's not if nobody
ever tells anybody about it you know the
sad thing is that some you know people
have theories like this work I'm doing
physics right now I I thought about how
this would work thirty years ago and for
a variety of reasons I didn't pursue it
as vigorously as I could have done and
frankly had it not been for particularly
a couple of young physicists who really
encouraged me I am I'm not sure I would
have ever gotten around to working on it
and and those ideas might just have
disappeared so I think you know it's
like is there science when nobody knows
it it's kind of like one of these you
know if the tree falls in the forest and
there's nobody there to hear it you know
in what sense did it happen um I'm not
sure I have a great answer for that
I suppose one thing I would say yeah
actually I guess I do have an answer
here's the answer I mean it's like
mathematics you can say there are many
possible forms of mathematics that you
could invent
there's the form you could invented
there's the axioms Euclid wrote down
there's Paul Kerr other kinds of axioms
the question is which of those axioms is
we humans pick up and say we care about
these or another way to think about it
it's like all possible languages could
exist you know we could be God or Allah
out talking in all kinds of gobbledygook
all possible secret
of you know of characters could be could
be being used or could be out there but
only certain ones have we chosen to to
say these are languages that we care
about these are things we care about
these are these are objects that we care
about giving names to these are things
that these are sort of mathematical
questions that we care about so in a
sense when there can be there sort of
can be an infinite set of possible
questions and science questions and
mathematics that are out there that kind
of in the case of mathematics that
abstractly could be studied but the
question of whether they are pulled in
to be something we can call mathematics
that we humans care about that is a
human question and I think I would
answer that from mathematics it can't
really be a mathematics unless there's a
human in the loop there's because that's
kind of what we mean by mathematics that
we care about and we study so when it
comes to science there are certainly
things that happen in the universe where
there's no kind of human in the loop and
where they're probably things that are
going on all the time in the universe
that if our civilization had evolved
differently we would be saying we really
care about that you know we see this
weird pattern in some fluid we see this
weird kind of you know pattern of flow
that right now we just say oh that's
turbulent fluid flow that's something
ran and we don't care about that but our
civilization could have developed
differently and that could have been the
most important thing it could have been
the thing where you know everybody
thinks that's really a critical piece of
understanding what happens and maybe we
could even have our developed our
technology that way I mean the way that
you know what tends to happen is this
very circular thing of we we know a
certain amount of science so we develop
our technology on the basis of that
science and then that technology defines
what happens in the world I mean once we
have you know the technology to make you
know aeroplanes then we have airplanes
and so we start studying the you know
the features of airflow and so on if
what had happened was you know we had
maybe oh I don't know well for example
one big one if we had computers a lot
earlier in history I think a lot of the
history of science would have been very
different a lot of things would have
developed if we'd had computer-based
control systems for things
we would have been able to build a lot
of technology that we don't have and our
experience of the world might be very
different from the way it actually is
now okay a question here can we access
other dimensions okay so so just to
explain a little bit about that I mean
in in um let's let's explain sort of
what other dimensions are I get to do
something on the computer again here let
me do something here so let's some let
me try and like explain a little bit
about what dimensions are so if we um
let's say we make let's do this let's
make a oops
okay now you probably say that's a
two-dimensional thing why do you say
that well you can move you can move left
right or you can move up down it's got
two dimensions you can move in okay so
now I could make something here which is
like um you know how many dimensions is
that well it's basically one dimension
because we get to move left right but we
don't get to move any other way well
let's do this let's make something which
is let's say we go I don't know eight
eight eight okay what's that that's the
thing I let's do the let's make this
make it a little bit easier to tell
what's going on okay
so that's the thing we can wiggle it
around we'd say that's three dimensional
okay but if you look at what I'm making
in each case it's always just a grid so
it's just something where I'm connecting
every point to other points that are
neighbors of that point okay so here I'm
connecting to the two neighbors here I'm
connecting to four neighbors here if we
counted out you'll find I'm connecting
to eight neighbors um six I'm wrong six
neighbors I apologize six neighbors um
the okay so we've got two neighbors here
that's one dimension we've got two times
the number of dimensions so it's two
neighbors here four neighbors here for
two dimensions six Nate
here four three dimensions okay so now
let's imagine we try and make one of
these grids but let's see what happens
if we try and connect to not three
neighbors but instead not not six
neighbors but instead eight neighbors
okay so let's try making well let's just
let's just show what would happen if we
make a a a two to two grid okay so
that's a so what is that well you can
kind of visualize that in 3d that's a
cube I can make it actually rotatable
here by doing this um okay so now I can
see that that thing which connects
everything to two well in this case it's
it would be if we had the whole infinite
thing it would be four neighbors but
here it's connecting two neighbors in
three different directions sorry six
neighbors it's connecting two neighbors
in three different directions okay so
now let's do the same thing with four
neighbors okay let's first of all just
do it like this so what I'm about to
draw is a four dimensional object in a
sense in the sense that every one of
these points is connected to four
neighbors just like here in three
dimensions every one of these points is
connected to three neighbors here every
one of these points is connected to four
neighbors and I could say okay well how
do I actually realize that what I could
say oh let's make it in let's let's put
it in three dimensions I can certainly
make that in three dimensions here and
okay I can move it around that's a four
dimensional object being rendered in
three dimensions previously I had a four
dimensional object being rendered in two
dimensions but that's a a four
dimensional object being rendered in in
three dimensions so I can have I can
make up this object at a sort of
abstract level I can just say I'm making
an object and it's four dimensional the
problem is that in our actual physical
space we only get to move in three
dimensions so although we can
mathematically make this up I mean I
could go ahead I could make a five
dimensional objects see what that looks
like okay so there's a five dimensional
object in terms of the way it's
connected together but it's still being
being I'm just showing it's like it's
like I could show a three dimensional
picture and perspective in two
dimensions this is showing a five
dimensional object in in three
dimensions that I'm moving around here
so abstractly we can perfectly well
define higher dimensions the problem is
that in our physical universe we don't
seem to have more than three dimensions
now actually I think that our universe
can actually have a little bit more than
three dimensions can even have not even
integer numbers of dimensions which
makes which is kind of a weird thing but
in in most of space we are mostly seeing
just three dimensions and and so we
don't have we don't have the ability we
cannot physically construct a thing that
is more than three dimensional now I
would say that in some existing theories
of physics there's an area of physics
called string theory that I think is
very mathematically interesting I think
it's some I don't think it's quite right
physically but I think it is
mathematically very interesting and very
relevant even to things I've been doing
but in string theory in order to make
everything work out nicely for the
mathematics it's really convenient if
the universe really has 26 dimensions or
10 dimensions and to explain why we
don't really see 26 dimensions you have
to kind of imagine that the extra
dimensions are all curled up into little
balls and it's actually honestly in in
the is it a plausible theory theory
question and the question of is that a
plausible theory if you start describing
it to somebody and you start explaining
it well we don't see 22 of those
dimensions because they're curled up a
little balls it sort of starts to seem
very implausible but the answer is in
our physical universe we seem to only
have three dimensions I actually think
it isn't precisely the case that we only
have three dimensions in fact and I
think that there are whether we can in
our current universe access things that
are effectively different numbers of
dimensions is not clear although I
suspect that some phenomena related to
black holes may have something to do
with that coming soon tune in for when
we get to really talk about physics in a
little while um okay I should I should
really wrap this up I've been going a
ridiculously long time
um I this has been such fun for me I
hope people have had a good time um the
this was really fun I should do more of
these um
so I'm I if people are interested I'm
happy to continue this at a different
time tomorrow I already signed up to do
an introduction to to computation for
kids and others and that is at he says
trying to find his calendar that is
slated for 4:00 p.m. Eastern Time
u.s. Eastern Time um which would be one
one and a quarter quarters hours before
this time um so well thanks for asking a
lot of really interesting questions and
thanks particularly to the younger folk
who had particularly interesting
questions um and you guys I just want to
say you guys have been very motivational
for me because you're interested in
physics is really is I mean I was kind
of wondering you know we've got things
to say about the fundamental theory of
physics I'm not sure anybody is gonna
care you guys are a great data point
that yes there are people out there who
care so thank you very much and thank
you for coming and I hope to do another
one of these into your course so thanks
a lot and bye